We got we got to hold me over there. We got the guards.
You in your family.
What's your opinion on?
On. I know.
The comments folks.
No, see.
Oh, I, I, we love them.
Again to have enough of them.
Hey, Riff, some inside please.
It's no point in asking these all of these guys have come back, especially their family.
They're the loyalists. They have the most power granted by the emperor.
That's why she can do what she can. I always know when he's able to do that.
Not of the houses of disability.
What's up to you about these? We need that before we go in to be prepared for what's to come.
He loves first name. We'll talk about it.
We'll just kill them. But she has the hand.
You heard them. You heard them. Come on.
Kill us first and then we'll talk arrangements.
See, that's not how a deal works. Does it?
See, that's how a deal works when you don't have power in the deal.
This is a reasonable ask. All I'm asking is for for guaranteed safety for me and my sister.
That's it. You want to do anything to anyone else? We're fine with it.
Help. We'll join you. Well, no, actually, no, I don't know.
I give you my word that I will not touch you.
Now, see, you said it in a way that makes me think that's your line.
I need guarantee, as soon as we heal you, we will be out of this play.
As soon as you heal us, I will let you go.
I think I'm not here. You're correct. You said you will let me go, but not the other people.
No, he said he'll let you go.
Okay, yeah, you see, that's my exact problem.
I want all of you to let us go. Not just him.
See, this crew easier.
I'm the captain. What I say goes wrong.
Disagreeze.
I always think my six is a nine.
Okay, she does not believe you even a little bit.
Look. Wait, is it a car? You have advantages. I'm a Christmas.
Do I? Yeah, yeah, from your captain, whatever.
Pingas. From your role. I just can't have disadvantage. I think.
Okay. That's right.
Yeah, she doesn't believe you. Yeah, it's only on purpose.
Oh, I see. I see.
I mean, if you stick to your word, you can still roll a persuasion.
I mean, I'm not going to hurt her. Okay.
That's what I've been saying that I won't hurt her.
That's better. No, she will not be deceived by a seven.
It's not deception though. I'm telling the truth.
Yeah, I wish I believed you, but I don't believe you.
How the fuck is she going to believe you?
I said, I won't hurt her. That is true.
Okay, that is true. But all right.
She's going to go. Okay, look, if I demonstrate my partner, and if it works,
can you just let us go then?
It's gotta be everybody. Everybody or nothing.
No, no, no. I will give you one of one of you I will heal.
And then then I will heal everyone else as soon as you know what?
Let's go with that. You promise me you won't hurt me.
So I'm going to heal you. Fair deal.
You will solve.
Now see, I can't do that. I've had enough of this.
He, Rufus is going to just point the shot gun at her head.
You know as well. Now you have one choice.
Which is he either heal us or you die.
Is that an ad 20? Oh my god.
It's that 20.
All right, well, I don't know.
You wrote privately.
We can't see.
Yeah, let me.
Oh, oh, nice.
Let me do public for now.
Where's public rules?
Public rules. Yeah.
Okay.
Well, I guess she's going to buckle.
Here she goes.
All right, I'm trusting you.
Rufus, if any of us do get hurt,
don't think you will survive once.
Well, you're not going to survive anyway.
So I'll just heal you whatever.
She checks her throat.
This is the one that you did not
crush the throat off.
So she she can still
his her vocal nerves are still intact.
She's going to just look at everyone.
She goes, all right, everyone now,
former circle around me. She's is going to move between
and there you go.
And she's just going to.
She's going to do her high note.
But this one is not to kill anyone.
This one will full recover everyone.
So everyone can take a short rest.
It's a long rest.
Just make sure you have your long rest.
Don't take any long rest, you too.
And you know which which two I mean.
You know, that's what fuck everything up.
What's two?
Let's forget about it.
Nothing.
Okay, I'll do him.
And him.
Oh, let me actually change his token.
I changed his token.
There you go.
There's her handsome man.
Who the hell is that?
That's a cake or a cake or a cake.
I like whatever.
I like it better as the tiger.
Now there's there's a tiger one. Don't worry. There's a tiger one too.
He puts on a mask.
Where the tiger one?
Bob, you good?
Where's Bob?
Yep.
She will recover.
All right, cool.
All right, so as soon as she hit that note,
she is also going to wake up the the one who was unconscious.
And the guards are two kind of waking up.
This point she looks at the guards and she's going to nod.
The guards start pointing their guns toward you guys.
I'm bashing your skull right.
You're taking her hostage, right?
She isn't between all of her.
She's going to just going to look at the guards.
She's going to ask them to point their guns down.
Okay, okay.
Come down everyone.
We don't need to do this.
Koda has asked them to get inside the broadcast.
Our job is done.
She looks at her sister.
She goes just be ready in case they want to kill us.
You know, just just be ready to try.
Well, I did my end of the deal.
Are we all good?
Where is it?
Come on.
Which way is this tower?
Basically, this this whole thing is like crushed
under whatever like explosion happened here.
So this whole wall is like gone.
And the tower is essentially like this far, this building.
Okay.
I will walk out.
I said I'd leave you.
I will.
Who which one are you hitting?
The guards or her?
I'm hitting her.
I'm going to tell the guards that they could leave.
Okay, 13 does does hit her to the damage.
This is to kill her.
Yeah.
Okay.
What do you do?
How do you kill her?
Literally.
As I'm going to be like, all right guards, you can go turn and pan like overhand
drilling down to her head.
The one who can speak.
The one who can't speak.
She's fucked.
She can't speak.
She I ruined those chords.
All right.
That can you do an intimidation with advantage?
Yeah.
Two days.
I was just looking at it and doing anything.
I want to do say.
Yes, yes.
Yeah, okay.
That's going to, Fredner.
She's going to try to run.
Which one?
This one.
One that can't talk.
Yeah.
Tegor grab her.
Okay, wait.
Guards get out of here.
Who the fuck's talking?
No idea.
Oh my god.
No, it's my fucking Foundry thing.
I don't know what it, what is this?
Okay, Tegor is going to try to grapple her.
Tegor does not have a lot of strength.
Oh, he just needs a stall for a second.
Nope, he missed his bump.
You want to do something?
Nope.
Okay, Bob is just going to let him go.
All right.
Oh, she just healed us.
She didn't know the one that he killed.
Yeah, that one.
Oh,
that she's already.
And she, Bob is just confused.
There's two of them.
All right.
She ran away.
Dramat, do you want to follow her?
Yeah, she's going to be too fast for me.
Yeah, I can only move.
I can only move 30.
You can move 35.
Okay, 30.
She's what she could probably move 40.
She will be too fast.
No, she's not asking.
I'm going to be too slow.
Well, yeah, you'll have to follow her to see where she goes.
You're going to see her from here.
All right.
What's the,
Riff's just going to go just let her go.
It doesn't matter.
Riff ain't going to try to shoot her with a shotgun?
No, no.
He's giving up.
He is looking at Cadence.
He's just taking her away.
And he's just going to say to her,
just go to the
hideout, make sure everyone's safe and
I'll be back.
She grabs his hand as he's leaving and
he goes, I'll be back.
I'll make sure.
And he's going to join you here,
Babthes.
Oh, are you ready?
The guards are gone by this point.
They followed her.
Let's put it into this.
All right, let's go.
Okay, as you guys go,
you can go through the wall.
There's still a lot left.
How are we going in there now?
Yes.
Oh, what about my shopping?
What shopping?
Like the store.
I told you there would be no time.
What do you mean?
Literally,
I'm going to give it now.
No, you have everything.
I'll just say you prepared it before
the tuning, the tuning fork thing.
That's fine.
You can prepare it like pretty quickly.
But for the rest of the stuff,
you prepped all of this way before.
So if you want to change your spells,
tell me what spells you want.
Which ones do I remove?
Which ones do I add?
I am spending my money.
So I'm getting new spells.
Chromatic or then,
hold person.
Let me get your money.
I know.
Chromatic.
Orb.
What else?
You need a pretty gold pipe.
Bob.
What am I right?
Did anyone hear what he said?
Chromatic orb and hold person.
A whole person again.
So the whole person,
you could have popped that right there
and held her so I could have got her.
Yeah, I was not doing anything.
That's a stag.
All right, so hold person and chromatica
orb.
I've added both of them in.
Just check.
Chromatic orb.
Hold person.
All right.
Okay, for the next section,
I'm going to just tell you what happened in between
till the first floor,
the ground floor essentially.
So as you guys major way through,
Baptiste, you were a bit behind the crew as you get a call.
None of the crew heard what the call was about.
You heard the call.
Do you remember the call, right?
Yeah.
Okay,
Malfus, you see the thing.
Okay.
Near like the entrance of the broadcast tower,
the gates slightly open up as this like gust of
smoke comes out of the gates as it blows through you.
Everyone walks in.
Baptiste puts the attendant mushi that he got a call from in his pockets
from way behind everyone.
Malfus follows.
Malfus, you saw something and you went inside.
Near the blast doors.
On the first floor, Riff just says to all of you,
I'll handle this one.
We don't have much time.
Maybe the emperor wakes up and maybe none of us make out of this life,
but I'm going to try and get this key.
And he's going to just,
the floor is essentially in like the stairs are going up in a spiral.
At every floor, there's a door that leads into a room.
And that room is essentially where each of the soundless five is stationed.
One Riff goes into one.
Baptiste and
Cade have a little conversation.
And he asks to stay behind and help Riff.
So he's going to leave with the Riff and enter the door as well.
On the second floor,
now you guys can take over.
The one that needs to be has gone.
What left chat?
What?
What left PC?
Bob is the second floor.
You know, we're just going to say everyone just push Bob in, close their door.
Bob, get in there.
And, yeah, we're going to, we're going to leave to the next floor.
Is that me?
Yeah.
Where is Bob, bro?
We got to figure out if there's maybe here or no.
No, he told, he told us that he was going to have connection issues.
Like last time.
Did he?
Yeah.
You know what?
That's this is go forward.
It doesn't matter.
All right, on third floor, now everyone's still walking up the stairs.
Go ahead.
Oh, I got a catch for a breath.
Why is there so many fucking stairs?
Did they hear about an escalator?
Bob, I'm over on what?
Whoa.
Suppose this wants me, huh?
Yep.
Need it is.
All right, let's do this.
Good luck, Rama.
Old man's stretch here comes.
All right.
Yeah.
From here, I'm going to.
What up?
Fuck shit up.
Oh, you already know it's just getting fucked up.
I'm waiting on this.
From this point on, I'm going to I'm going to move everyone to their individual VCs.
And we're going to take over.
Me, duplicate channel.
Level.
One, two, three.
There he is.
Bob's here.
Bob, we push you into your door.
Yeah, we just push you in the floor and they left for the next floor.
So good luck.
That's what we said as well.
All right, this is going to be Roma's room.
Roma, let me know if you can see a new VC or not.
All right.
There you go.
Can you see it now?
Lunar fold.
It should be something level.
Yep.
All right.
So I'm going to remove yours.
I'm going to add.
Bob.
There we go.
Present.
All right.
Bob, can you see your room?
Oh, is this?
Oh, OK.
Yeah.
No.
Are you OK?
So you guys hang out.
I don't know how long it will take for you.
We've got just a private duty.
So you say something.
We don't set you here.
What?
We'll just set that individually waiting.
Yeah, there's no point for you guys to sit there individually waiting.
You know what?
I'm going to add you into one.
So just sit there.
But they won't be able to see that you're both there here.
So that's fine.
Just put it in Bob.
That's the best one.
Just suspected.
What the fuck's up?
No, I don't know.
They're recording into drive.
You can look what happened.
Do what's Robo's going to do.
Do it on Bob.
I'm going to I'm going to upload the whole Bob
Bob fight into the fucking server somewhere.
All right.
Let me.
I'm going to run this around.
Yeah.
There you go.
Can you guys see one of the VCs, both of you?
I think level one.
I see one and two.
Yeah, yeah.
So you're going whichever you both can see.
There's one that you both can see.
All right.
I'm going to look to Bob.
Hello.
Okay.
What is this?
You are going to fight one on one with one of the soundless
five.
Oh, good luck.
This is going to end.
This is going to end very badly.
Well, we'll see.
We'll see.
All right.
Can you see the map?
Yep.
As your best friends push you inside this room,
as soon as you enter, can you make an athletics check for me?
Dex or athletics, whatever you want to do.
That's fine.
Dex meaning can I do acrobatic?
Yeah, acrobatic.
Okay.
You barely hung on to essentially as soon as you
got into this room, the, the, there's like a gap right below you.
And you just essentially fall in, but you were able to hang on
the floor with one hand using your mechanical arm and you pull
to yourself up.
And you see this room is very weird.
There's stairs going up and down.
There's holes, cabins and just just all around.
Very, very weird.
As you enter, you also see
the same guy that you saw on the rooftop.
Change the music.
Where is it?
There we go.
And he is essentially walking up this ladder,
like upwards, not like downwards.
He's walking up this ladder, standing like vertically on top of the ladder.
And I'm going to show you his token.
Just give me one second.
What the hell do you show?
There we go.
This is the one guy that you saw on top of the wall,
like who was crouching on top of the wall.
He looks at you.
He goes.
Hey buddy.
I see that you're the one I'm fighting.
Yeah, that's a bad luck.
That's a great.
But that luck for me, you seem awfully confident.
For someone we'll find out.
Okay.
Now, let's have some fun, shall we?
He, you see when he's like talking to you,
he has his eyes closed and he's like essentially like
watching you through his like slitted open eyes, like narrow eyes.
As soon as he opens him, you find yourself
right here.
And this is essentially like a cliff,
but you're standing vertically on it.
If you understand what I mean.
Okay.
Yeah.
And he is also going to disappear and right up here,
right before you.
Okay.
Now you can enter.
Come back.
Or for initiative.
All right, let me see if we are on a different combat.
Yes, we are.
All right, let's go.
It's your turn, Bob.
What are you doing?
I don't have much to do except for in everything that I got.
So I'm going to do a second level chromatic arc with Harris goggles and just
hope that I hit.
All right, go ahead rules for chromatic orb.
What type?
I love just where is the chromatic orb there?
First level, second level.
Yeah, does it require an attack roll?
Yes.
Okay, can you make it with disadvantage?
Okay.
All right.
Private team will.
Yeah, roll in private.
Click private and then roll.
Yeah.
So does that hit?
Is it good with disadvantage?
Yes.
And I have Harris goggles.
So that's an actually a 19.
Yes.
Yeah, if you tell me that doesn't know it, okay.
So, come on in all it's 38 is 48 and with Harris goggles it will be 58, right?
All right, rolls for damage.
Oh, God, please.
For one.
Okay.
25 damage.
So what does chromatic orb does?
So this is like a since these are the guy, they got, I mean, they haven't seen much of the
stuff. They would probably know a lot of devil truth.
So he's not going to do any kind of lighting thunder or flame or cold that he had seen the other guys use.
So he's going to throw a, a cannon opens up in his hand and he's going to throw a vile from
that cannon and shoot that and it's filled with like bright green like emerald colored
chemical that when it hit them, it burst into acid which starts corroding.
That has a damage.
Holds him.
Yup.
As this, the splash gets on his body, you see the threads that he has on start to boil away.
And part of the skin starts to burn. What's eerie is that he doesn't really care.
Definitely does damage him, but he just keeps smiling back at you.
Well, well, I think.
Think that you would be able to put up a fight, 10 boy.
As soon as you throw it, do you have anything else you want to do?
No.
Can I move actually in this play?
You can try to move.
Oh, I can try to move.
All right, I'll try.
Okay, can you go away?
Make a dc's, sorry, constitution save.
Okay, so as you, where do you want to go?
I want to move like right, go over here so that I can get like protection from the
stairs that I can hide between you.
This is like a drop.
The complete drop around 10 to 20 feet.
Oh, you have to go here?
Yeah, if you have to go here, then you have to make a jump to get to here.
I will not do it because I don't want to jump.
Okay, what do you want to do then?
Basically this whole place is like we, the both of us are on top of a cliff or something, right?
This place is a cliff.
This is a cliff.
This is also like a bit downwards.
This is upwards.
All right, bottom back.
I'm just going to stand there.
You're just going to stand there.
Do nothing.
Okay, then you didn't have to make the con save.
Okay, that's fine.
Okay, so.
Next, he starts to move closer to you.
As he's moving closer to you, your ear starts to ring.
The arena kind of hums.
It's just a constant, like, humming sound in your ears.
Every step that you take, like, around you,
it feels kind of heavier.
Every thought that you start to think of something seems to be lagging
as what you're trying to do.
So if you want to move your arm,
it moves a bit later than you think it should move.
And as you start to notice these changes,
you see a cross from your rhythm is standing and just,
you know,
funny thing about time,
you only notice it when it's taken away.
And he is
going to
use his sonic hammer.
If it's an attack roll, he gets the call.
Thank you for increases.
Is this the attack roll?
Is it a three?
No, it's a five.
Okay, it's a four.
So as he is trying to get close to you,
and he essentially raises his one arm with this,
like this blade that he has attached to his one arm.
He raises that arm.
As you see, the air pressure starts to bill around it.
And a sonic wave essentially comes towards you.
What do you do?
What do you do to essentially not make it happen?
To not make it happen?
The moment that happens,
he just starts the mind-controlled thing that he uses
with detect all the detect thoughts,
and he starts standing in wave the moment he's done this.
So when the rhythm is coming here,
he's trying to do,
you know the thing that an automatic noise cancellation
headphones do,
do they send the opposite kind of rhythm?
He's trying to do that to cancel it out.
As you do that,
he notices his arm.
He looks at you, he goes.
He just might not be such a bad match then.
Not at all.
He starts to move towards you still.
At this point, he's going to just look at you straight in.
It's your turn.
So when I hit him with the first thing,
so like with everything that I got,
he just, nothing happened to him, right?
Well, it did the damage.
It seems like nothing happened to him.
It didn't bother him at all, no.
Right.
Well, I am going to run from you, my guy,
and I'm going to pass levitate on this person.
Okay.
Do the levitation.
Is it an attack or what?
No, it's a saving throw and he gets a five.
Okay.
So as you do that,
can you make
another constitution save?
With advent, okay.
It doesn't matter.
Okay.
You're trying to get your
small little thingies around him on his body.
What's the, what's the save?
Roll the spell.
No, he gets a five.
He gets a five.
Oh, okay.
Oh, yeah.
I just want to see that.
Roll your spell.
So the spell slot is used.
He rolls a five.
Let me see.
Okay.
The little bug start to attach to his legs
as they just flip him up and hover him over.
Where do you want to levitate?
How high?
20 feet.
The highest.
Okay.
Highest.
So he's 20 feet above this ground.
As soon as you do it,
the arena gets flipped and he's going to just stand on the wall
and you are now falling toward the wall.
Can you make a dexterity save?
Chief, what?
Okay.
You don't take any damage.
But essentially, as you start to move and you let your
bots out to grab him and just like thrust him upwards,
as soon as he sees himself getting thruster upwards,
the arena starts to move and it's not something like
you notice it at all.
You just find yourself standing and then immediately just falling downwards.
And you gather yourself, you land on your feet,
but you do see him standing against like at the bottom of the surface.
And now, if when you look up, you see where you were.
Essentially this place, but you're like upside down.
So where is he from now from me?
He is still next to me.
He is still next to you, but he's a bit,
because of like the levitation and like the space distortion,
he's a bit away from you.
But he essentially grabs his one of the blades and just sticks him
himself up in the wall essentially.
But that's also where gravity is also pushing him.
So he's just fine.
Oh, okay, so that was my turn.
Yeah, that was your turn.
Someone's got tricks.
Tell me something.
I'm curious.
What are you doing?
You don't seem like a person who much cares for anyone else.
Hey, aren't you the one who blew down the fucking bell?
Yeah, I don't really care about any of this.
And I feel like this was a wrong decision.
No, actually, he doesn't say that.
He says that I really don't care about any of this.
And normally I would never have done that.
And I would have never come here up,
found seeing what you guys can do.
But when I first came into the island, I saw a lot of stuff.
And I saw a kid.
His mom was killed right in front of him.
And then he was thrown into a jar.
And he couldn't do anything about it.
That reminded me of some stuff.
Maybe this was not the right logical decision,
but and maybe I won't get out of this.
But I do not regret this.
As you're talking, he takes one of the other blades and essentially forms like the same
type of shockwave sends it to you.
As you're still talking, the shockwave just goes behind you, hits the wall.
I don't see what's so wrong about that.
The mother was killed, the child was killed.
Someone got hurt at the end of the day.
The balance was restored.
That is our job.
And you, my friend, are trying to stop us to perform our duty.
So you need to be put down.
You are asking a lot of questions about morality and stuff.
What's there is no doubt about that.
What?
Oh, you know, how strenuous they do their things their way.
I don't really get into how squabble,
ever since the emperor decreed the decibel decree.
You never had any family?
No one you cared about?
Well, I do like my family, but I don't really care for them.
The other houses though, I would like to take on
them at some point, but Kota disapproves.
Here we are.
I was so good.
That's your turn.
So I have just found out that I can't do anything to him.
So I'm just going to keep on blasting and hope
that the other guys are finished before me.
So that the other guys can finish their fights before me and then
and come here.
So I'm just going to keep on blasting.
What do you do?
Another chromatic orb.
Blue.
Go ahead.
A check rule disadvantage or normal?
Disadvantage.
All the time.
What can I help?
Okay, tell me that.
Does that hit?
Yes, that is.
Another acid again?
Yep.
Wait, wait, wait.
Did that Bob didn't, what Bob saw?
He saw that that guy wasn't phased by that, right?
Yeah.
So he's going to do poison now.
He's going to try to change the stuff so see what he's damaged by.
Okay.
You do see like the acid did burn his skin.
Okay, I'm trying to get a reaction out of this guy.
This guy's like a wall.
Yeah, again, the poison gas essentially at this point just burst in front of him.
He does not seem to be even dodging at this point.
He doesn't think anything you do is going to hurt him.
He just keeps the levitation essentially still hitting him.
He's still pushing him upwards, but he grabs like one of the knives and just
keeps like stabbing it into the ground as he's walking his way towards you.
And the other poison just bursts right in front of him.
You will take the full damage.
Do you have anything attached to this poison?
Does it do like?
No, nothing else.
Take damage, no?
No, okay.
All right, I'm going to move the fight to Roma at this point.
And I'm going to come back in a bit.
All right.
Hello, hello.
Did Bob win?
No, no, no, no.
I just stopped for a bit and now we're going to do some of your fight and then I'm
going to do some of Melva, some of my teeth, so on.
All right.
All right, let me know when you can see the map.
I can.
I don't know why I can't.
Okay, now I can see it.
Okay, nice.
All right, all right, Roma, as soon as you enter this place, this place just seems like a
in-house jungle of some sort.
You see trees, shrubs, bushes, everything just lined up
and just like water running inside the floor is completely covered with grass.
Even the ceiling is completely covered with like moss and grassy bits.
Yeah, and that's it.
Okay.
Yeah, as you enter inside, you don't really, at first glance, you don't really notice.
Anything?
Well, what do you want to do?
Well, you said it's like a forest, a jungle type.
So, you know, you know, Roma's going to be sitting there looking for ingredients.
All right, go ahead, what do you want to look for?
Where do you want to go?
I'm literally going to walk straight up where like it kind of opens up into that circle.
I can't move for some other reason.
It won't let me.
You know what?
It says.
So I'm just going to be like, I'm going to walk up and like, I'm going to start looking at all the bushes off to the left, off to the right
and see if there's anything that I could possibly use.
Okay, can you roll for investigation?
Yeah.
I said your rolls do private, by the way.
I think, I think, uh, already did.
investigation.
All right, um, you don't seem to be able to find anything.
Let me see.
I hope to God, I have my rolls at the private.
Okay, uh, what's your passive, uh, perception?
10, uh, as you like, try to look around, you hear like an echo and then after that echo,
uh, a bullet essentially goes through you.
Goes through me or like, let me, it hits you right on.
Uh,
and you don't even know where the sound came from as this like whole room essentially echoed as soon as the sound
uh, came and you're going to take
uh, how much do you have resistance to anything?
Bloodling, uh, no, not in this form.
Okay, you take 20 damage right off the bat.
Uh, as well as you get pushed into like these trees
and as soon as you just land on that tree with the like a huge gash in your shoulder,
just pins you to the tree and a body just plops over in front of you.
Can you do a, a perception?
Yeah.
Perception.
Another one will be dead.
Oh, very bad. 13. Okay, 13. The body right in front of you is a
mink's body. It's dried up corpse that's like carvings right into its like body like chest
is carving like like someone like didn't autopsy essentially on him and just ditched him back up
and like hung him through the trees. As you start to notice a bunch of bodies again, again
on like the lining of all of these trees just hung up.
It's like some sort of like ritualistic, sadistic way to just, I don't know what
we can't understand why. But yeah, are they all minks?
They are all mink bodies. Yes. Oh, fuck I'm dead.
So yeah, it's up to you. What do you want to do? Because the gunshot
essentially came from behind you. So you were standing here.
The gunshot came from behind you. You don't know where.
But the sound echoed all throughout the room.
Come on, pussy. Let's fight. Am I like under the like in the bushes like can he see me?
No, whatever it is, they can see you.
So I'm going to pop one of those. Fuck I'm going to have to eat both of them.
Yeah, I'm going to have to pop both my treats while while I'm sitting there like listen to
her pussy. I can't see you. You know where I'm at roughly. But like
you can't see me. Let's settle this like men in the middle. Come on now.
While while I'm trying to figure out where the fuck those things are, is it Gorman?
That makes sense. Yeah, Gorman. Gorman, you click Gorman and then there should be
me in treats. What's the metaheel? Metaheel I think is for long rest. Let me check.
As an action you can inspect and drink as a part of short rest. You can metaheel.
Yeah. Okay. With one hour of work you can create your treats.
How much do the treats give you? I think it's 1 to 4. No, I think it's just 4.
Okay, so 8 total if I pop both of them. Yes. So that's going to be 32.
As you're walking, you're walking outside or you're just going to stay in the bushes.
But I'm going to try to like move like I'm going to have to roll a stealth. I already know.
But I'm going to try to move like because this is all bushes. He shouldn't be able to see.
As soon as you go like face me like a man, a woman in like large like robes that you saw on top,
like the third woman right right on the left side of that man that who was speaking. She steps up,
she goes, "What if I'm not a man?" It seemed like an easy prey. I don't need to.
"Waste my effort hunting you down."
All right. Can you enter combat role for initiative?
Yep. Got them.
Come on now. Come on now.
Well, you should have.
Is there a way I can move that search bar? Oh, I can.
Yeah.
Oh my god. What did I do?
You rolled for initiative?
Yes. I did roll for initiative. You are, I think, supposed to go first.
You do see her right in the middle.
And she does see you. She has a big ass rifle.
Fuck.
How far away is she?
She's 35 feet. You can move in. You can move in.
Yep. You know I'm doing that. I'm moving.
So movement would be my action, right?
No, no, no. Movement is just movement.
Oh, so I saw an action, an an bonus action.
Well, she pissed me off because she shot me.
And I'm swinging for the fences.
Okay. Go for rage.
Rage applies on you. There we go.
Yep.
And then now let's, let's swing. Come on now.
Let me pull that back up.
Let's skill it.
Come on, smack this shit out of this bitch.
As you like start to run and go into rage, your body flexes,
and you keep running on all force at this point.
And you try to just hit her with the skillet.
There's like a tone that just amits from this woman's body.
As you see, like around her neck, she has like these metals.
And they resonate as soon as they, as you get close.
Can you do the attack with this advantage?
Oh, you're attacking recklessly.
Yeah. You have to do it with normally.
You have to do it normally.
So normal attack? Okay.
Fuck, that doesn't hit.
Does it?
The neck?
No, that's not going to hit the arm, the metal armor.
Send for you.
Your skillet just hits like the metal part of the armor
that she is wearing.
And that's just knocks her way a bit backwards.
But that's about it.
As she points her rifle towards you,
I'm going to take my sweet time carving her body as well.
You're at a wolf.
She's going to...
Cunning action, just engage.
Just remember.
Yeah, yes.
Even when you just get sent, I just want to make sure.
Try to pop her.
He's going to try to...
You already know I'm doing it.
So it just be normal because it wouldn't be with advantage
because the reckless is normal.
13.
That one's got to hit.
18.
Total.
18 matches her AC.
So that does not hit.
God, you're too wide.
You swipe at her.
She just ducks down and she keeps sprinting
and she's going to use her action to hide.
So I know roughly she went that area.
Yeah.
She's going to go that way.
Here we go.
What was the move on the meat check?
Move 20 feet.
Okay, so I have a question.
So I'm a wolf.
Would I be able to smell her like anything?
You can try to do perception and it depends on how well
of a stealth she pulls.
Okay, so you just let me know.
Yes.
God damn she ran.
This is what you're going to play right into my fucking week.
This is bro.
So I know she ran that way.
Can I measure that?
Oh, is it my turn or is it hers?
Yes, yes, it's your turn now.
Oh, my bad.
So I'm going to move the 20.
That still gives me 15.
Yes.
Like right there.
Why?
Just give me one second.
My head wants to just do it.
Okay, so it leaves me a 10.
One, two, three.
Yeah, go ahead.
What were you saying?
Right, that's the 19.
You do smell like the sand because you've got a bit close to her.
You do smell it.
But as soon as you like to try to track it,
it just spreads out everywhere around here.
Okay.
You can pick either left or either right.
All right, you go left.
You hear some movement around here in this part.
All right.
Every reckless, it's just by default.
If you're close to her, it's going to hit with normal.
So just do normal.
Yeah, that messes.
As soon as you swing in the bushes, she just jumps out
and like steps on your head and just jumps back out.
She is out now.
You can see her.
She is on top of like a branch on this tree.
She's just going to try to hit you.
Can you make a...
She's pretty close.
She's going to do it with disadvantage.
Okay, yeah, she does not hit.
As soon as like another shot of her goes through,
it just misses you completely.
Let me check on the critical.
The target.
Good, that's fine.
Yep, she's just on top of it and she's going to use her
cunning action to disengage
and run away here.
But she's not going to hide you because she used all her actions.
You can see her walking around here.
Oh, God.
Oh, did you do self-roll because I can't see your
roles anymore?
Private GM.
Why can't I see your...
I think anymore.
Can you roll something again?
Just stopped.
What's happening?
Are you sure you're on private GM rule?
Let's check again.
Okay, can you do...
No, I think blind GM, I can't...
You know, I just...
Why is it not working?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it's stopped for now.
No, my roles you can't see because I'm also doing
private GM roles.
That's fine.
But your roles I should be able to...
Okay, it's fine.
You missed right one.
This is not going to hit. She keeps moving as you try to swing your
skillet on the branch.
The...
It bounces off the branch and you grab it again.
It essentially repels back to you.
But she got away.
And you...
Yeah, you do see her as you...
The skillet bounced off of it.
Another dead,
winked body just falls on top of you.
And it's again, starved, stripped, cut open.
Just not to kill.
It's just to see what's inside.
And knives are still buried in the flesh, like markers.
And the ground is just soaked with old blood and
just everywhere, just blood everywhere in the bushes.
She is going to...
Yeah, it's your turn.
That was her turn. It's your turn now.
You can't see her now.
Yeah, yeah.
Maybe like a fish, you sure.
Tench? Yeah, yeah. You can try to do that.
If you get close, you can spend like a reaction to like maybe slip something on her body or something.
You want to see what...
What did you eat for the treat?
Let's just say that.
[silence]
You like dark white?
Yeah, sure.
Yeah, as you...
You can spit on her and that stench would be on her.
From now on.
Once you get close and if you can spit on her.
All right.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
She's still like around the bushes as you're like chasing her down.
You close the distance. What are you doing?
Yes.
But if you hit, if you hit, I will say the attack roll will...
Is going to be the attack roll for the spit and the spit's going to land on her if you hit.
Do normally.
Mm-hmm.
[silence]
[laughter]
Sure, sure, sure.
[silence]
Go ahead, roll, roll, roll for the attack.
Oh my god.
[laughter]
[silence]
Iruba, as you move around to swing your skillet on top of her,
you're not trying to hit her at this point.
You just try to like leave some center on her so she does not escape.
You try to swing.
It just completely misses as you like spin around in her circle.
And as you're trying to like lick her face, she just goes,
"Yeah, she just punches your face. She's running away."
And she's going to just disengage.
Do your Sentinel.
And say, "Teen, again, it matches the AC, right?"
I have no idea why I was not showing the rolls.
Yeah, you just go public.
Uh...
Yeah, you did have a bonus, actually.
What do you want to do?
She hasn't gone away now.
Mm-hmm.
Now, what do you have as a bonus?
Let me see.
You have second wind.
Oh, you can also pop frenzy.
You can also go hybrid.
Okay, try again, try again.
No, no, you didn't.
Okay.
She runs away.
Your Sentinel did not hit.
Is you tried to hit her as she is running away.
You, uh...
At this point, she's going to again hide.
Uh...
Ta-da.
Who will still for her?
I'm also making it public.
I got 28.
Yeah, this should be enough.
Okay, she's going to just disappear in these bushes.
All right, go ahead.
It's your turn.
Uh, you know what?
I'm going to pause here.
I'm going to go to Bob.
Uh, sorry, I'm alphas and I'm going to come back.
All right.
Guys.
Bob's gone again.
Where the fuck, bro?
I left for like 10 minutes for Roma.
He's gone.
Oh, there he is.
Hello.
Ready?
All right, let me go to your floor.
All right.
Uh, where were we?
Let me go to...
There you go.
Uh...
You did your move and that's when we switched, right?
Okay, it's his turn.
All right, he's going to look you down and he goes,
and talk about morals with me.
And she went apart.
And she know what parts do.
I don't think you're in any position to judge us.
If anything, you're the one disturbing the piece of this
great nation.
And he's going to just put up his fists against you.
And he's just going to do the sonic hammer again.
Yeah, but he has two arms and two of these weapons.
Uh, it's not going to...
I don't know what he's doing.
Every time I try to roll, it's just not anything.
You're lucky this time.
I don't know why.
It's your turn.
It doesn't have a boneness, yeah.
He's not moving.
He's just trying to like,
hold himself and just shoot at you from...
Uh, from there.
No.
You're still concentrating on the thing, right?
Laptation.
Do I have to do anything to get out of the repetition?
Or is it just permanent?
Oh, and he has not done that.
Okay, cool.
That's great.
Cool, go ahead.
Roll with the...
Is it an attack or...
No, it's not an attack roll.
He's going to succeed.
As one of your bullets try to...
Uh, hit him.
He just blocks it off with the knife he has and just lice his through.
Well, don't you have an answer for me, pirate?
You're going to stand there and be on this small high ground forever.
Uh, and he's going to try to shoot you again.
I don't know what is what is happening.
He's just not hitting you.
All right, it's your turn.
What do you want to do?
No, come.
Because your DC is 14.
Yeah, uh, he's going to fail this time due to the damage.
Yes.
Eleven, as this bullet this time just curves around his blade.
He's trying to block it again and it just embeds one of the bullets.
Just goes straight through one of his arms.
Uh, he's going to take...
Okay, 11 damage.
And he is just going to...
I guess we're not talking then.
Uh, attack.
And it's going to hit.
Can you make a...
All right, do see the barbs.
Move on.
That's fine.
As long as both of us forget it's one.
Uh, all right, let me make the attack roll again.
He is going to fail.
At this point he just seems annoyed.
He's just going to let...
Whatever he was holding on to on the wall to let him not levitate.
He's just going to let it go and he's just going to roll again.
Attack with this advantage.
Oh, sorry.
Go ahead, dammit.
Disadvantage.
There we go.
Yeah, that's going to hit.
Uh, and it's also going to throw you away.
Uh, damage.
Normal.
The first sonic hits you right in the chest.
And the second wave just throws you away.
As it throws you away, you again, the layout of the room shifts and you start to fall down.
Uh, you have to make...
First to concentration.
Okay, you fill the concentration.
He's also got to stop the bots essentially on his...
The thrusters on the bots starts to give up and they just...
Images, we just latch off.
Uh, can you make a dexterity save?
Why is the music not working?
What is happening?
[laughs]
Oh, you were also just...
Yes.
Uh, the music is just not working today.
What the fuck?
What the fuck, man?
[silence]
Okay, uh, right now your body should be around here somewhere.
And he is going to be around here.
Okay, uh, dexave, you fall and uh, roll.
2d6.
Will it take eight damage?
But you have human feet, which is...
No, you're not human.
[laughs]
I'm not mine.
You're not human.
And you're more.
All right, you are down.
All right, I'm going to move to Roma.
And I'm going to come back at some point.
[silence]
Geee, some big...
Let me...
Yeah, let me go to the third floor.
There we go, it's your turn.
Uh, there we go.
Hmm.
Geee is hiding, but you also saw her last here, around here, in this area.
Uh, and so for some reason, my music's not working anymore, so let's just...
Great.
Oh no, it's working.
Hmm.
All right, go hybrid.
You don't need a token, you just click hybrid.
Click hybrid and then use ability.
Click transform in the chat.
There we go.
Why is it not updating your...
It is, it is.
Okay, it's slowly updating it.
And not updating your token version?
I don't know what's happening.
Anyway, you're in...
Yeah, it's not updating on...
Okay, there you go.
All right, you're in your hybrid as you just get on all your force
and the clothes start to rip at this point.
And you are in your Yeti form.
What are you doing?
[Music]
Oh, I don't hear it.
The music is fine.
For some reason, I just don't hear it.
[Music]
Okay, what are you doing?
All right, go ahead.
We're in the direction you're pointing at.
Hmm.
[Music]
But it'd be like towards like this area.
Roughly like...
No, just do rail frost.
Does it not let you like put the...
It says attack.
After...
Yeah, it doesn't let me put the token down.
Just do it with the...
Yeah, it's not going to hit.
Goddamn it.
As you rail frost, let me check what it does.
What does it do?
Is there any description on it?
Um, a frigid beam.
Okay, make a range spell attack against target on a head that takes one day of damage
He'd reduce by 10.
Damage increases as you level up the spots.
Okay, that's 20.
Yeah, as you do a rail frost in front of you,
you do hear some movement in the bushes.
So at this point,
I'm just going to try to...
Shoot you.
Normal.
Isn't that 20?
Jesus.
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
Do it.
It is what it is.
This is how Roman dies.
It's how...
It's how Roman dies.
You're fine.
You have piercing resistance.
You're not going to die.
Also, you have 44, 10 HP.
But that's just going to burn through all your 10 HP.
Why is it 44?
It's turning to be 16?
Yeah, that's 16.
Why does it always go to 24?
No, it did.
I was only at 76.
Does my normal health is 44?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
16.
And then 32.
32.
16.
48.
So...
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry.
Yeah.
So, 40 minus 16.
First that.
So, 24.
You take 24-year
real HP.
So that leaves you with 8.
You're still alive.
But you do fall down.
It's up to you.
How do you want to play it?
You want to pretend to be dead?
You want to stay alive.
I'm staying up.
I'm going to have to do this.
Okay.
I'm going to have...
I'm bleeding, right?
You are bleeding profusely.
This one just shot through your like gut.
Basically.
I'm going to have to try to hit her again.
This time, I'm going to use my inspiration.
She is.
I'm going to make sure...
At this point, you are pre-torn up.
She's going to try to come near you.
She goes, "I'm going to take my time carving you up."
It's a lot of space, right?
All right.
I'm going an all-out bro.
Like...
All right.
I got at least hit...
Your turn.
I'm going all out.
So like...
I'm...
recklessly swinging...
with...
and I'm popping frenzy.
So I'm getting that extra swing.
And I'm going to pop that inspiration point.
Or the...
for the key or whatever.
I don't know what it...
Okay, okay.
You know...
Now that...
Go ahead.
Like...
I gotta...
I gotta at least do something towards her.
Like...
So...
And it's recklessly.
Just letting you know.
It's like...
I'm swinging twice...
like...
All right.
So this one's...
for just the first attack.
Thank you, sweet Jesus.
Yeah, it's...
23 is hitting.
And then I'm going to do the frenzy.
So then...
That ain't hitting.
That's Italian isn't it?
18?
Why does it not show up here?
Oh, you have to roll again.
For every time you hit, you have to roll again.
So see, it replaced your earlier one.
The 23 with 18.
Oh, so I have to do the damage.
No, you have to...
Click on the skillet again and then roll again on the attack.
18 does not hit.
But if you want to pop your inspiration,
that will give you plus three on your AC.
So that's going to be 21.
So both of them hit.
The second one.
Okay, so...
Yeah, what else do you want to do?
That's all I can do, right?
Let me check.
Because that's...
That's my action and bonus action to pop frenzy.
To do my other attack.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
So then yeah, I'm doing that where I...
Roll damage for...
one and then roll it again.
Okay, so then...
The next damage would be plus...
nine, okay.
And then roll again for damage.
Oh, it was nine again.
Was it nine again?
Did you roll again?
I don't think you rolled again.
Yeah.
Here, uh...
Yeah, I rolled again.
It won't let me roll again.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
So you have to just kill like on the skillet again,
do an attack roll and then do a damage roll.
Okay.
All right, so let's go...
Get back to my skillet.
Sorry, I closed out of my tab here.
So then...
Oh, I can just click damage if...
No, no, it doesn't let you do damage anymore.
The fucking new foundry is stupid.
It's 17, so it's still gonna hit.
Yeah, it's good.
It's fine.
It's basically the same roll that you did earlier.
Yep.
Okay, so mine and...
13.
Do you have any bonuses in this form?
Uh...
I thought I had like...
Electro?
Yeah, the plus...
Yeah, the plus five for Electro.
Is it plus five or do you have to roll for it?
You can choose to do lightning attack when this damage.
Once you hit with the weapon, you can choose to deal...
Yeah, just click on Electro.
Do the damage.
Okay, roll the damage.
Electro, where the fuck's the Electro?
It's in your feats.
That's where I thought I was at.
In your feats tab, it should be under race features.
Yeah, just roll damage.
Okay, four more.
So, four Thunder.
Uh...
Per attack, right?
So be...
No, I think it's on the first draw out of the check.
I thought it was whenever you hit.
Yeah, but I think you can only do it once...
Once per turn when you hit with the weapon,
yeah, once per turn.
Okay.
Uh, four, and then it's gonna be...
12, and then it's gonna be nine, right?
Yep.
Because I don't think I can pop second win, because...
No, that's another bonus action.
Yep.
That's gonna have to be next turn.
Hopefully I can make it.
Okay, um, as you swing your first, your skillet,
you bang on your legs as he trips,
and you're gonna try to hit your, hit with your skillet again this time.
You feel like this energy, this rage inside of you burn,
and the skillet just turns for one second, like completely black.
Have you bang on your head as this like black electricity just burst out,
and that's gonna do another 2D 10 damn, 2D 10.
That's for your inspiration point.
You're essentially coding your skillet in Armament Hockey.
It's 17.
(Pause)
As she takes like a bit of damage, I see she gets pulled out.
Uh, and at this point she's just...
uh, pissed at you.
If you're not really care at this point, she...
crocs.
She throws away her rifle.
She puts like a...
wild, essentially like a green liquid, while she pulls like a small gun.
She puts the vile inside, she goes, "I've had enough of this."
We're in my new experiment now.
She's just not pint the gun and shoot.
Let me see if she hits.
That's not 20.
I don't know, I'm not making this shit up, man.
It's crazy.
She's...
Yeah.
In this fight, like...
Yeah, crazy.
Okay, as soon as like the vile hits you, it seems like an injection.
It's not like a bullet or anything.
It just hits you right in the chest,
as the liquid starts to burn inside you.
And we're gonna continue here when I'm done with the rest of the guys.
I'll be back in like 10 minutes.
Okay.
Bobby Boy!
Bobby Boy?
So, I have already finished making a new character.
Okay.
Well, you wanted me to.
Before that,
I am going to let you do your level up now.
Okay.
So, you have a free action.
You can replace your core.
Essentially, at this point, your core has become unstable.
As you fall to the ground, you see,
as soon as he hits you with the other attack,
the core kind of popped out.
And you remember, like, you have another core prepared,
and you remember earlier in your...
When you were hanging around with Ronan,
you tried to protect him.
The explosion that happened was because of your core.
What do you want to do at this point?
Well...
Take a gamble.
Tense it.
Exploding.
Might as well.
All right.
Level five.
What do you want to do?
Well, I don't get anything else except new,
two new spells, though.
Let me...
But you do get all your HP back.
As soon as you put your core inside the new core, replace it,
you get all your HP back and everything.
Okay, can you go and level up your character?
To level five.
Where I'm going to level up my character.
Yeah.
Go to edit.
Go to features.
Then around at the top, you should see...
Is there a...
A small, four to five?
Take average.
You can roll.
If you get roll...
I don't want to roll.
If you don't want the max...
If you don't roll lower than the average, then you can pick average.
But it's fine if you did it.
That is awesome.
Well, yeah.
I knew it.
Okay, just pick five then...
Or six.
Whatever.
Just click...
Click...
Yeah, click take average in the next.
Okay.
That's it?
Yeah.
Okay.
Let me move...
Pretty simple.
For a wizard.
I know.
Fireball.
There you go.
And void.
Shrek, there we go.
All right.
Do a long rest.
Oh, it's a long rest.
So do I roll my portance again?
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
Okay, I did my long rest.
Roll your portant.
Okay, that's actually really good.
That's a nice spread.
All right, let me explain what happens.
Please, for the love of God music, please work.
Why are you being so rough?
Can you hear the music?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Can I hear it?
Why?
And I hear it.
Okay.
As you fall down, in midway, as you were falling down,
you pull out one of your fireballs and you throw it at them.
Roll your fireball.
She's not going to dodge this.
So he's going to fail willingly?
He's not going to fail willingly.
He's just not going to notice the
small core landing right around him.
So mechanically, does it do anything?
Because I don't do stuff.
Oh, you want to do stuff?
Okay.
What do you want?
I mean, mechanically, does it change anything?
Because if it doesn't,
if it doesn't give him disadvantage or something like that,
I want to use my portance on it.
It's not going to use it.
Fireball is fireball.
There's no attack or roll, right?
There's no...
Oh, there's a saving throw.
Yeah, but that's going to be with this advantage, like I said.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, but you can...
You still may have to use for every success this advantage.
Right?
Oh, yeah, true.
So...
As you swap out the core,
you put the new core inside
as this new burst of energy.
If you want to swap your current source of power,
which was solved,
you want to swap it right now,
you can swap it.
What do you want to swap?
No, I keep solving.
I keep solving.
You want to keep solving.
As you click it in,
the new surge of energy just goes through your electronics
and it heals your like broken up limbs
and everything, the human parts.
And you feel renewed.
All your mechanics get an automatic upgrade.
Everything you prepared gets ready at this point.
And you can use whatever you want.
And I'm going to do a...
Dexay with this advantage.
Well, you're all the same thing.
18, he's going to succeed.
Well, then he's going to fail.
Okay.
What's the...
I lost the die?
18 and 3, I'm going to lose the 3 now.
3.
As this small core,
this point is very unstable.
It's starting to move around as this small core starts to get more,
more unstable.
Rhythm does not notice at this point
and it's going to explode in flames.
Do you want to roll for fourth level,
fireball?
Sure.
So 96.
Yes, just roll 96.
Not bad.
Oh wow, it's pretty bad.
I rolled a lot of 2 and 3.
But okay.
You can...
And then, important does not work on damage.
Nope.
Right.
You see like his limb.
One of his limbs just gets blown apart with this explosion.
Now you're completely renewed.
And...
And his explanation doesn't change?
His expression, this time it changes.
This time he did feel the arm getting revved off.
And he comes out of the smoke
and you just see like big splotches of like just burned skin
on his face, his other arm,
and he just walks out of it.
I've had enough of this.
I'm going to tear you apart from limb from limb, Chengyan.
Oh, so you do feel pain?
And he's going to attack with the sonic hammer twice.
The first one gets disadvantage.
If it hits, then it's very barbs.
Yeah, the first one...
Does it hit?
I forgot that I have to roll twice.
I have to click on it twice to hit twice.
15 doesn't hit.
No, 21 does hit.
Silver barbs?
Silver barbs on that.
He's going to fail.
I did take a long rest, right?
Yes.
So my first talk...
I got it.
Yes.
Okay.
Okay, the first sonic wave goes right by you.
The second sonic wave goes right by you.
If you want to move, you can move towards him.
I can move now.
No, I don't want to move towards him.
So...
That's my turn.
As the first sonic wave goes...
Around your first half, he starts moving towards you.
The second wave goes around you.
You're essentially at this point,
he's just basically dodging his moves.
You can see it very clearly coming towards you.
And you figure it out his trick.
Okay.
All right.
And that is...
Okay.
Oh, okay.
So I basically understood.
Yeah.
You basically understood what he does.
What does he do?
This time...
I...
This is above board.
Yeah.
I am going to...
Bob knows it.
I don't know it.
Okay.
Bob knows it.
Can you roll a straight intelligence for me so I can tell you what it is?
Oh, you want me to roll.
Yeah.
Rolling intelligence so I can tell you...
I got an 18 to my roll.
I got an 18 to my fucking roll.
Okay.
Yes, I got an 18 to my fucking roll.
I'm going to use up all my cordon.
Okay.
You essentially figured out his technique at last time as soon as you moved.
The room shifted.
Even if he pushes you away, the room shifts.
It's because of some ability that he has.
He essentially targets one person in the room and changes the access
of the room depending on that one person's position.
That's his ability.
That's what you figured out.
Now, we're going to...
Right.
You want with that?
So I'm going to hit him with everything I have again.
Okay.
Yeah, I'm going to hit him again with everything I have.
So, hell of goggles.
And I had advantage from Supervars from the last time.
Mm-hmm.
So, uh...
So, advantage than hell of goggles.
Uh, second level, chromatic orb.
Let's go.
Go ahead.
So, do I roll with advantage or...
Roll with advantage.
He's not close enough to you to impose the disadvantage.
Uh, is it in hit?
Wait, 16 actually because it's hell of goggles.
16.
16 does not hit.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I used the hell of goggles.
Nevermind.
Okay, as you throw...
How much global is permanent for?
It's not one hit.
Is it?
You said it was one spread long range, uh, long rest.
One plus attack roll.
No, no, no.
Actually, oh, one spread long rest.
Okay, yeah, sorry, sorry.
Okay, this one misses completely.
What do you want to do next?
Do you have any bonus you can do?
I don't have any girls to do.
No, no, no.
He keeps walking down the stairs.
What happened?
Where are you staying?
Still a move, damn it.
Uh, he's gonna send like a shock wave from the ground as he like
stomps his foot against the ground.
Uh, can you make a con, Sue?
Oh, that's an advantage.
I'm gonna plant it.
The shock wave goes through the ground at the same time
that the shock wave travels to you.
You just jump over it, land again, uh, and let me see if that does have damage or no.
Uh, I guess not prone, shouldn't you then?
Okay, half damage.
Okay, let me do...
Uh, you take six damage.
Okay.
From the remnants of that, uh,
shock wave.
He keeps, he keeps closing in the distance, but that's his move.
So he's pretty much, uh, he's not right next to me, is it?
No, no.
Uh, and uh, I can't use my other level 3 spells, got to do another fireball now.
You can't use fireball, you can use any other spell.
Okay, I will upgrade any spell to level 3, you can do anything you want.
Yeah, what should I make sure to just shoot him?
Yeah, I'm going to...
What is, what is the working focus?
Oh, this is a guy.
Yeah, I'm going to...
Oh, uh, I'm going to shoot...
Good.
Uh, damn it. I'm going to run away first.
No, I'm not going to run away first.
What the fuck am I going to do?
I'm going to do levitate.
Again, let's do this.
I can't see it, right?
Uh, no.
I, um, I can't make my up my mind.
Let's just keep hitting him.
Attack.
Normal or disadvantage?
Disadvantage.
He's close to you.
The...
Close to you.
The humming, the humming increases as soon as he gets close to you.
So that essentially goes you off.
Okay, that hits.
How am I rolling so good?
The panic.
Yeah, that's crazy.
That makes no crazy.
Actually insane.
Alright, go ahead.
Go at the D8.
48?
It's level 1, right?
Uh,
No, no, second level.
Okay, second level.
Oh, no.
Good knowledge.
Wow, this is so low.
Yeah.
Uh, what type?
Yeah, after the...
Okay, we're changing it, right?
So let's keep poison.
Alright, poison this time again, right in his face.
It seems he seems very annoyed.
He keeps...
Just stop with this nonsense.
I'm going to fucking murder you.
Ah, it hurts so much.
Uh, and he is going to...
Keep shooting at you.
Well, that's...
It's going to be with disadvantage because he's too close.
Oh, nice.
Now we're talking.
Let me know if he's not hit.
Nope.
Okay.
He's not hit both of them.
Uh, he comes closer again, essentially.
This time, it's just he just faced right in front of you.
He just hits you.
You dodge.
He just hits you again.
You dodge again.
What do you want to do?
Well, it's a...
It's a standoff, then.
We're just kind of keep on shooting each other.
Let's fucking do it.
I'm going to shoot him again,
but this time I'm going to use,
since he's right next to me.
I'm going to use, told the dead.
[Music]
He fails.
Oh, nice.
So, 2d12.
One level up, told the dead?
I'm at level 5.
Oh, yeah.
It's a can trip.
Oh, how am I doing more damage to the can trip?
18, that's crazy.
Okay.
Yeah, the bullet just goes straight through his shoulder,
the arm that was ripped off of,
and it just like tears off another portion of that limb, essentially.
Now he goes.
Let's see how you take this.
He's going to pull slam again on the ground.
Let me check if he...
He gets it back though.
We charge success, nice.
Wait, what happened?
Okay.
Can you make a con save again?
He takes both the things,
like the weapons in his anislams the ground with them.
Yeah, you fail.
Oh, damage.
I'm going to be going down again.
Damage.
Let me...
No, you don't go down.
But you do go from...
Noctbro, you do get noctbro and stun until the next turn.
The shockwave essentially hits you,
it's box up with your like cheering,
and you just get confused for one turn.
It's going to be...
Paid.
Like the pain stop.
He takes something out of his like pocket,
and you see like the green oil that you saw back in Hallow's
laboratory in Calisto.
You see the green vial as he turns the wild,
the six-six like the markers on the wild turn upside,
and it forms like an infinity symbol,
as it clicks and needle pops out,
and he's just going to inject himself with it.
And you see this transformation happen,
as his body just gets the other arm,
just grows back,
and he...
My friend, you did not need that buff.
I was already going to lose.
Oh, damn, this guy's scary.
He essentially like turns his...
His body turns into like this weird,
amalgamated form of like an animal mixed in with human futures.
And yeah, it's just going to...
At this point just grab you,
and try to kill you.
It's going to do...
Well, that's his move, essentially.
Oh, it's your turn now.
You're not stunned anymore.
It's fine turn.
Okay, so I'm going to get the hell out of there with Mr. Step,
and I'm going to shoot him.
How far is he?
Where is the like closest normal ground that I see,
not any vertical or longitude to the motion?
Here, you can fly up to here.
You can essentially trust yourself and jump on top there.
Yeah, I'm just...
I don't want to move because that stuff just problems.
I'm just going to straight up over here.
Mr. Step is teleport for you, right?
Yeah, yeah, exactly.
So I'm just going to straight up to the door over here.
Okay, as you teleport away,
that's your bonus, what do you want to do?
And shoot him with my...
I told it again.
Was I'm safe?
Nice going to fail.
Do the damage.
2-12.
3-10.
3-12.
1-2.
Oh no, there you go.
And he is going to...
He hows.
And your ears start to ring again.
Can you make a wisdom save?
I am not wise.
That's your problem.
Well, I guess I am.
Yeah, you succeed.
The...
How essentially does not affect you?
Rhythm at this point just seems frustrated.
Okay.
Let me recharge.
Try to recharge now.
He doesn't recharge.
That's his move, what do you want to do?
And jump around and he gets around up to here.
He's visibly bigger than before, for sure.
Right.
Do I hear the things that I was hearing and that gave me a disadvantage on stuff?
The humming, the humming at this point becomes like screeching.
But yeah, you can hear it.
He's too far away though.
For now.
It's not that loud.
In that case, I should...
I should use up my other third level.
And...
Because I don't have anything else to do.
I'm going to roll attack.
It's normal.
I'm getting that.
It's going to hit.
26?
Nits?
Yeah.
Okay, explain to me how this happens.
So weird.
When he's just coming here and running at me and Bob is scared right now, but he doesn't want him to know that.
So he wants to do the thing that I want to do.
He doesn't want him to know that. So he wants to do the thing that is going to make him feel scared.
And he already saw the thing that in their dreams, like a stylist or something.
They were doing the fear thing.
And after that, he tried to experiment with chemicals and see if something that can do the same thing again.
And when he found that gas out, he used that to make a bullet.
And so he just points his finger at him.
And it opens up, shoots the black bullet at him.
And when it hits him, it's just darkness surrounds him in smoke.
And the gas, he inhales it and becomes frightened of him.
Okay.
The 26 damage.
No, for one turn.
And for one turn.
And he's frightened for one turn.
He is frightened.
He's not going to do anything.
It's your turn again.
I think he has to, if frightened creature has to use up their action to run away from the target.
Yeah, for some reason this creature sees you and he's going to just repel down.
You can see something that he doesn't like.
Again, let's shoot him again.
Aren't you out of your level three slots?
Is the concentration spill?
What?
Wait, strike?
Yes.
And he did not hit me.
So I still have concentration.
Is it?
Ah, not a hit.
As another one of these bullets flies to him, it just misses him completely.
And at this point he will snap out of whatever confusion he was in.
And he's going to just...
I still have my bonus action on this turn, right?
Yes.
I'm going to miss to step again and go further away.
Like probably about...
Yeah, like about here.
There we go.
Use your miss to step.
Just because we don't want any left over spell slots.
He's going to use his dash.
He's going to try to...
You don't have to place the thing.
It's automatic.
Oh my god.
What the fuck was that?
It's a fireball miss.
Fireball, I see.
He's going to move 40 and then...
40.
Another 40.
He's going to jump off on the walls.
You see him just like teleporting.
Not teleporting, just like running into the wall and then walking on the wall and jumping on this side.
Basically he uses all like three dimensions to just walk and move around.
Doesn't the gravity in this place doesn't seem to affect him.
I can't run from that.
Great.
So does he use up his action to dash or...
Yes.
So again,
board strike.
Let's go.
Is he close to me?
Or can I...
Put the concentration on it.
I don't understand how a white strike works.
It's a concentration spell and...
As long as he doesn't hit you,
you can keep doing it again.
Okay.
Yes.
Yeah, that does it.
Okay.
Not good damage, but he is frightened again.
He's frightened again.
He just runs down this place.
This is just...
It's your turn to drop off luck.
I need to keep doing this and not lose my concentration because I don't have any other spell
sort of left.
So attack again.
What do you mean you have...
Level one strike.
I did fireball and board strike,
so I don't have any level trees for both of us.
Oh, I see.
Okay, you hit him again.
Oh, sorry.
Sorry.
Hit the wrong one.
17.
17 does hit.
Yeah.
Hold for damage.
Oh my god.
19.
You're essentially just shooting all your...
Bullets the stock that you have left and just embedding it into this...
Yes, I'm emptying my magazine.
Yeah, it just creeps...
It just keeps running away.
It's frightened more and more and more.
He's too far away now.
What's the range again?
I don't think he has to run away.
He just has to...
What?
It says...
It's the frightened condition then...
Really?
Yeah.
Pre-tuned condition?
Yeah, frightened does not make him run away.
He just can't move toward you.
Oh, sorry.
I...
I missed her.
All right.
Well, he's gonna stay here.
Okay.
Oh, don't help me.
Don't help me.
That's your turn.
Again.
As long as I'm not hit,
I'm just gonna keep shooting.
Okay.
Do the damage.
Not hit.
Okay.
Use the...
Our frightened.
Okay, go ahead.
Your turn again.
Oh.
It'll literally take only one hit for him to...
Make sure I lose.
Yes.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Your turn again.
Oh.
It's...
Yes.
I don't have anything else that I can do this much damage.
I don't know why you didn't just use Wage Shrye instead of the...
The Fireball has less damage to him.
The Fireball has not had that much damage.
I mean, that was me rolling bad, okay?
I rolled a lot of two.
Fireball normally does like about a really two.
Go ahead.
You're just getting incredibly lucky, man.
I don't know what that is.
Yeah, true.
I don't know how I'm hitting him with a normal attack.
I don't even have advantage.
And did I jinx myself?
Let's be.
I did jinx myself.
Did you not roll damage for the first one?
19?
Yes.
It's...
Oh, I did not roll that.
Yeah, I should roll damage for that one first.
Oh, God!
That's...
That's same damage as Fireball.
Exactly.
Yeah, it's gonna...
Again, just...
Friedham and even more and more and more and more.
You see his body is like starting to crumble.
Whatever fluid he just injected in himself
is just trying to like make its way through it.
He is conscious.
He knows who you are.
He can't talk.
He has spoken before in this form.
But he...
Yes, and cannot see...
This time to where do you?
This time I miss, right?
This time you do miss.
I am going to miss this step again and run away.
Oh, I'm running out of slow slots.
God damn it.
Where do you want to run away?
Uh, back behind...
Around this place.
Okay, he's gonna use his dash and just run towards...
Stop!
Hurry away!
All right, it's your turn.
Oh, so now he's right next to me.
That means I have to do disadvantage.
Yes.
God damn it.
Oh, with disadvantage, does not hit.
My lads run out now.
And that's gonna... what's around? Is it 15?
That's crazy.
Yeah, he's just finally just going to...
Let me know if I hit.
Oh my god, does he miss?
No.
My AC is 17.
Yeah.
He does it, he does it.
Okay, so Silver Bar.
Yeah?
Roll Silver Bar.
There it is.
You just trying to bite you at this point?
Wait, after my long rest I did not do any Silver Bar.
Right?
No, I don't know.
So this one will be free because I get one free per long rest.
He's gonna miss 15.
Okay, so I'm gonna hit it, I'm gonna shoot him again since I still have my concentration on
and I get the advantage from Silver Barbs and disadvantage from him, so normal roll.
Yeah.
How is this guy still standing after all this?
This could have killed me like 19 of 20 times.
That damage I did.
Okay, this does not hit.
I'm not gonna hit and the next...
Okay, I think.
And now we aren't turn 16.
I'm gonna move to Roma and then we'll...
Okay.
Hello.
Hello, hello.
All right, let's see how Roma dies tonight.
Let's see how he does.
All right, so Roma, the last bullet that she injected in you after that you fall unconscious.
You are in a dream.
You are in the dream from your childhood.
You're running after...
What was the name of the girl?
I can get it.
Oh, sorry.
God damn.
Let's look here.
Oh, God damn it.
It's my eye.
Sheeran.
Yeah.
It's Sheeran.
You are running behind Sheeran trying to catch her.
You playing a game of tag.
Uh, Roma, tell me...
What?
You want for level...
Let's level you up.
Oh, I already told you.
I want that fighter.
I want to get the two attacks.
Can you...
I reverted your Sheet.
Can you double-click your Sheet?
Go to Edit and click on Fighter 2.
Edit...
Fighter...
I'm on the Sheet.
Yeah.
I click...
I click Edit.
It doesn't let me change Fighter 2.
In the drop-down, does it not let you fight her plus 1?
Go to your Feetstab.
Feetstab.
There we go.
In the Feetstab, you should see Fighter
and then a drop-down right alongside Fighter.
Yep.
And then...
Oh, hit points.
Uh, hit points.
Roll for it.
If it's lower than the average,
then just click on Take Average and then Next.
Uh, Roll Decent.
[Roll Decent]
It was two, so we're taking the average.
Yeah, just take Average and then Next.
Action Surge.
Let's go.
Hell yeah.
Alright, Ruma.
Uh, uh, uh, in your dream, you are chasing after Chiru.
You're back in Zou.
You're just having fun.
And for one second, your eye...
Eyes goes dark and now right in your hands,
you have...
Can you click on...
Inner Beast?
Yes, sir.
Inner Beast.
Feets.
Click on Media Transform in Inner Beast.
No uses on interviews activity in this new turbo no
transmitter non-midi transform engine uncheck unchecked the box
okay
oh
unchecked the box yes, I check the box; the click
Click on Transform in your chat
okay
you have gone complete so long
and
oh
you have a vanish on you have in your so long you have plus four to your
strength plus four to your decks plus 10 walk walk
and you from the new one you get one attack from action search
so it's up to you what do you want to do at this point you are in
your like complete truly beastly form you have no sense of what you want to
do you just see anything in your way and you just want to tear it apart
yep, oh I got to see what kind of
because if I have that spell
oh
let's look here feats
is it feats?
no I think it might be spells
let me
oh because if that's the case
you are essentially like twice as big as you were last in your normal form
your hair is just flowing and this is
oh you know I'm swinging you know I'm coming out swinging this is what you
know right right now that is fucking dope oh I'm taking I'm swinging with the
pan you getting
you all right go ahead roll for damn
that roll for hit okay so for every move this turn you have it managed
oh right so we uh we are attacking
and bayage
22 okay so then let me roll the damage for this one
max damage and then I'm doing same thing yes
so
none of those are hitting fuck
oh man that's your what was it that was your extra attack 13th yeah that was the extra
attack so my second action serve so I'm fucking I'm full beast load right yeah we we
popping this so for my boat is action I'm swinging again like you go you go see oh god damn
and is this with advantage too yes every every action this turn
oh what every action oh that's that's hit 21
all for damage
15 15 and what was the first one 13
yes
can you double that for me please so 30 30 and then
13 would be 26 28 28 and 241
as you essentially grab her and just bang the skillet right on her it's called bank
bank bank as you throw her away and you're gonna start moving toward her I'm gonna make a con
save for her
I'm gonna make uh wisdom save
okay yep she's gonna fail she's frightened for one turn
so is it my turn again yes just frightened for one turn okay
oh god I thought you just had a devil fruit how how is it that you cannot speak you're just
you're you're like beast complete for me you have no idea what's happening you're just
looking at her it's just fucking tearing her apart I'm gonna run like partial way and you know like
you know how like every wolf when it fucks something up right away it stops and howls you
won't hear that okay as your howl reverberates all throughout the the building everyone at this point
can hear you how hell yeah that's what I'm saying like and I'm all fucking walk back up by the way
if you use their natural weapons you get six attacks just say you know for next time because
natural weapons hit twice oh well I'm gonna use that shit right now like yeah but the problem is
is I have no nothing like when I look in the character sheet it's just all of aroma stuff like
no abilities nothing so it doesn't even show natural weapons no no no just the token click on the
token here double click on it on the on the map can you see natural weapons oh I do yeah
oh shit fuck that we're using that right now all right natural weapons skills
it's not six attacks now because you already use your frenzy and your what do you call that
action search action search is like one spur short-quest so you can only do four but yeah you can
do four all right say less I'll swing it four times
and every single one's with the van to just that's correct that one's it and
oh why did it just do it once I don't know but that one also hits okay
so let me click it two more times
bro that's fucking nasty
in your head you are just playing tag by the way that one's dead 24
that one does not head no one does not head so three heads to roll damage for the three
nine
eleven one more I'll just I'll just roll this one I know
yeah 12 11 and nine
uh yeah that's gonna kill her what do you how do you want to do it oh you know we go we all
swipe with the right gonna swipe with the left then we gonna take the claws and the mouth
and rip straight down the middle
great uh you run up to her you how you jump up you throw away your pan at this point and
uses tearing into her swipe from the left swipe from the right and then just tear
take her like head and just pop it off and just slice her in the middle
uh that's gonna be the end of the end of your battle
uh i'm gonna be hella exhausted
we don't know what's happening to you guess we'll know once we are done with the other guys
all right see you soon
all right Bob
present also DM uh did he hit me because uh i'm at nine hell uh i don't think so let me check
the damage log maybe i hit you accidentally because he did hit me then i am supposed to lose the
worst right uh no you have to do a concept right then you lose the yeah yeah yeah thing
i don't i hit you once but you never hit you after after the yeah after the thing
it did the ground smash and i check let me check it's damage
you get set 17 damage from one of the ground ground strikes but that was before you did the
white strikes that's fine okay all right uh i'm gonna go back to this i'm gonna go back to Bob
well he is right next to me right yes i have any lots to misty step uh i have one last
thought should i yes i'm going to misty step and run away
and uh where where do i run come here yeah uh come here so that i don't get this advantage and then
uh do the last strike of my life
well i guess so oh god that is more damaged than fireball
yeah he now that he takes that and that's it
it's your turn okay again uh yes
rinse and repeat uh i can't go any further i can't run away so this is my only hope
yes
yes you feel he's gonna just jump that distance and he is going to do a howl can you
just let me check if i nope he's not gonna do the howl he's gonna move and he's gonna bite
uh does he hit let me check does hit do i do it again uh does yes yes yes where is it over there
that's a nap 20 he has to keep the lower roll okay where is it uh
display in chat uh the chosen creature makes another
roll if the chosen creature is advantage i need to use the lower roll and use the lower roll yet
okay um i'm gonna do normal damage well i'm down i'm pretty sure i'm down
that's gonna be
21 well i'm dead it's gonna not gonna kill you because he hasn't killed you he's just down
yeah okay after this point you don't know what happens sure you're just unconscious
uh all right uh can you make three dead shapes from me
three dead uh um can i get advantage on the first dead save because i did the very
buzzer right before it sure okay if you die you die by the way yeah yeah yeah that's why i'm
wow okay fail one with advantage i fail one you succeeded second
okay one more please just one more
okay one more okay this is uh wow roll of the session
oh well okay all right so i needed to know uh okay the first two turns
where you succeeded the throw you kind of opened your eyes to see as to what is happening
around you you just see like this red gas bubble
not bubble like just just red mist around you you have no idea what is happening you just hear
a bunch of sounds and you hear like this thing crawling on your body
just something like a spider but you can't make out what it is for the second rule you see the
spider is like attached yourself attached itself to the core of your chest and it's starting to like
melded in some way you don't know what is happening and that's it all right
it's so funny it says Bob has in like Bob beyond Earth no Bob has died with three that saving
safe failures it's so funny uh for the new character i'm gonna give you some options if you want to
pick from them you can pick from them okay so do we do we do we do we do anything else or
hear your options let me show you your options one option is this guy
okay the other option is this guy the other option is the other option is this guy
the other option is this guy cute this is cute too this guy
do you know they're classes do I know they're classes this guy is a brawler right here this one
the fisherman he's a brawler all right he is a rogue he is a paladin he is a
artificer and this guy is a rogue and a fighter
i'm pretty sure we have a lot of fighters we need spellcasters i think i need to go with
paladin okay we'll talk okay it will happen okay so like end of and for today
if you want to leave you can leave i'm gonna break the news to the other guys okay
okay well it's a shame because i literally just reworked your
yes like it's level five then he down we do have one person that can revive you right now in this
area so in kid you know what just just hang on a bit i'm gonna see how the other guys do if they
do come down to check up on you because you haven't shown up they will come down check on you
if they do come down in time they are going to be able to see
you then revive like one minute yeah oh one minute from your what death death right yes no no no
no this is a completely different thing you are also a cyborg so it works differently it's not like
dnd revive so the ability of the user that can do the well i have hope then bob has hope
bob has hope because he's not completely made of you know yeah all right all right i'll see you in a bit
well
hello hello okay i'm gonna i'm gonna come back in like 10 minutes i've got to do
mouthfuls and baptize now i'll be back in a bit okay no you take your time you take your time
mochi mochi oh yeah how did it go um i guess we'll find out
i saw bob got to his second face but that's not the good thing i guess uh it's rough it's rough
bob was doing so well it's crazy he was doing so well but it's okay i feel like you'll find out
you'll find out bob's guy beauty that i really like what the fuck
um all right let's go to level two mouthfuls let's begin with you i'm gonna come back to about
these well here we go all right
hello hello hello all right let me go to fourth floor activate can you see the map
uh yes oh can you see yourself at zero hb sorry one hb
uh yes all right let me explain to you as to what is happening for your level up
um so the clouds above you are still there and as he slammed you down twice with his three times
with his hammer again and again and again each time the shock wave essentially shook your whole
body as these um the the the powder that you had in your pocket just spreads throughout around you
he's starting to walk away as he's starting to walk away you uh the the charges above the clouds
start to build up as these sparks starts to travel from from the clouds to the ground on those lake
dust of conductive electricity whatever right they start hitting tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt
and at this point this this thing has come completely uh surrounded you and while your
consciousness is fading away the lightning strike hits you once it hits you again it hits you again
it's you again it keeps hitting you keeps hitting keep hitting you your consciousness still
fading away as you see a hand grab you from this like see of just you just drowning and you get pulled out
and let me first uh let's level you up go to edit oh let's go from brawler 4 to brawler 5
i got a 10 on my roll i remember nice
exit exit thanks try let's go
there's 4 to 5 yeah 5 ball we were going to change there
oh can you heal up do a long rest
did that end private first private jam
no no it's 56 hb nice let me move here
must go to the right one at the other one yeah can you also click on hybrid form
i shard a long time
put it in there yes
you don't don't just click on the hybrid form that's it
don't transport
clicking click on it and just consume the resource so i can transform you
all right
let me let me actually let me actually oh god damn it you know let me revert this
let me change the thing a bit
do hybrid form again and transform as well
okay just transform this name yes
hey run for all right not correct what the fog
i'm on 45 hb it should be
wedding i know i know you know what i'm just gonna
why is it such a pain in the ass when i do it it works and when it's actually need to be done
it's not
uh it's only appearance right nothing changes in your
hybrid correct
it's a problem i don't know
longer duration and there's levels balls
you know what i'm gonna do everything
you know i'm gonna make the thing work somehow
oh so i already added like i already added the little spells last time
so we didn't have to do that in between the fights
no let's find this fine this fine
all right and you are awake you're blown awake
you have this new clause your whole body has these like carvings of your thunderbird your body
has like these feathers jotting out of them to the thunderbird this is your unlocked second
form of your devil fruit what is that mean you are back up he is walking away he turns around
you still have some life left in you huh all right it's your turn
20 right yeah
we roll the tie again the fighting die what fighting day oh yeah good people wait wait wait let's wait
let's wait let's well the second time it wasn't shit yeah it wasn't shit the second time
right around this time you also hear a howl coming from below uh this floor
i have this shake yeah i saw i saw Roma when she was long yeah yeah
all right let's roll at the 8 what could go wrong
i said i never got it free again action or is it a bonus action it's a bonus action
i mean look it should be a bonus action it just says action here for some reason
yeah it's a bonus action i saw it uh go ahead a little roll look at paper first see
why do you have two extra attack man what the fuck what do you mean it says two extra
attacks two extra attack feats for some reason that's fine fine thanks
and dollar where is that table it has two extra stunning strikes to what the fuck man
so everything all the dinner free what is that fucking table
uh it's just in swinging stance what did you roll yeah i don't see it nothing yet
am i blind am i just be blind
just go to swinging stance right click at it i don't see out here it is
it's a five see what is it oh oh oh when you use for you ignore the spirit coin oh my god
so so that's four attacks every time as a 12 at least do a bit you use a bonus action extra attack yeah
well them
uh let's what we're about to do is an action two attack rolls you can do right now
yeah i know uh whatever i do something else okay
but you make me a that's a
okay
he fails oh boy
okay do the damage
damage i think i might get all the 86
that's a lot of freeze oh 32 okay uh essentially as the lightning strikes you
out of the dust you come out with your new form your wings completely wide open as it blew away
all your clothes essentially the lightning and you just channel the lightning from the clouds
and just strike this guy right through the chest as the lightning just goes straight through him
that does 32
damage to him there we go as the lightning strikes just so straight goes through and hits the wall
oh there's me i guess i mean you have an extra attack
yeah i have no but that's an action first it's an action through attack wise oh i see you have to
use it as a attack just means that if you use the attack action you get another one
okay okay okay uh as the thing goes through him he buckles for a second huh
was he walking away and it like moves five more feet away from me it's like move away
i mean you can you can move away you have movement right yeah but it takes a day of a good day
well no you're attack head right
well no that i need to do the attack i should need to fix them oh you have to fix them okay
i need to fix them right yes okay uh i know that the the burst of electricity is just
going to shock him for a second you can move away okay uh
our uh mr. 23 oh sorry
oh let's go to the metal and
and also because fuck you don't fuck you hit me with the hammer
no nothing to force
don't fucking hit me with the hammer
i'm up yeah that's me let's see okay uh he drops the hammer for a second he grabs the hammer
again he goes i suppose you haven't concluded you do you yet very well he's just gonna
fucking bolt it and again just run towards you and try to hit you with the hammer have a better look
i'm 40 feet and yet oh i see yeah okay i played nice last time he not anymore okay he is going to
use shatter again
uh try to knock you out of the thing can you do a concert
oh yeah shatter in the pot seat
you fail you're entrapped in this uh shatter dome essentially in his zone but he can't get to you
uh it's gonna be eight damage
well actually five because yeah minus three
why because of the you i got to turn away i will have a mine five just a little bit more time
to speak yeah twelve okay you're trapped inside it but you can try to get out of it next turn
your turn that's this turn yep so that's 15 do you get back your thing every turn right if you take
damage you haven't taken your HP 10th HP uh i think i just you get 10th HP
oh that 15 go ahead oh that's things no the the three 10th HP is every time but since i have more
10 HP from another source i'll just hold that one for now okay the 10th HP doesn't add together
oh i see you see if you don't have any 10th HP okay yeah 12 yeah 10th HP you can
is just one source okay go ahead what are you doing you can get out of the you can get out of the
shatter using uh what was it acrobatic slettics what was it i don't remember whichever one was your highest
that's that's the plus eight acrobatic now yeah go ahead yeah you're out of it you flew
outside of that zone of shatter uh what do you want to do was that an action or a bonus action
it's not anything that's a fiat action oh oh yeah i'm a countdown and i'm ahead it i assume the
first one is a charged one okay the first one will be a charged one okay
when he hits let's go
that's decent damage okay keep going no don't disengage
attack attack
that hits
all the damage just to make sure yep that's a say okay that's 14 that's gonna kill him what do you
want to do oh okay so i'm just gonna charge down and wait can you open the character again
what can you open the character of him who's character oh his character
i'm gonna see what i can do with it there you go can see it
oh
pro players oh yeah there he is uh he has he does not have this shield anymore and the upper part of
his body is power down uh uh i'm just gonna again mess consecutively hit him through his armor
okay as you fly up you slam right into him you hit him first the first punch lands into like his
chest directly that crashes into the ground a large shockwave just goes through as this thunder
just rains upon around you and the other head just goes through right through his uh um
his armor you can feel like his chest but it does not like just go through the armor and hit his
chest that's it and he's gonna fall
okay can you do a perception for me
yep this yeah i know what's coming
what a sub charm
okay come on damn it now the
bit of anteris because i saw this embo i saw this embo before oh you know what do it do it a bit of advantage
yay
no what's the fucking point of seeing the simple yeah no what's happening okay
well your guard is too dumb uh his deception was 20 by the way not not not 20 but 20 um so
as you're starting to walk away he stands up you hear the armor's clanging as he
stands up you turn around you see him like get a while of something he pulls off his like
marker uh sorry not marker the fucking helmet it throws it away you see he resembles his brother a bit
but his body is actually like that size that he's inside the armor is very like thick but not as
thick as to make like very distinct like body sizes the body size is pretty much around that
he takes the while he turns it around you see the two six six symbols uh rotate and like attach
into like an infinity as he stabs himself with the opened up a while and he looks as he goes
and i was not i'd i would get to use this well let's try what this is about
as he starts to turn uh he you see his body starts to change he uh starts to burst out of that armor
okay uh something they now change completely then the don't have my movement speed of hybrid and
resistances i have no idea what's happening
just in the thing you know what i'm gonna just i should how much damage did you take nothing right
so i'm just gonna move you away from here well if the shadow was a that should have only taken for
god damn it uh so annoying why does your token also says a different thing you know what i'm
gonna no you know what i'm gonna remove you from this encounter remove goodbye i'm gonna delete
your ass bleach well
i swear to god foundry fucking work oh i can't i remove your token
is your token gone or no no i deleted myself okay nice thank you that's what i was trying to do
for like the half half of the time uh there you go i think this is your one right you have everything here
you're checking everything is here or not you put two again
what because on my business form two no no one
sorry what do you mean yeah yeah it is form two right yeah do you not have everything here oh i see
see you don't have anything here restore transfer from yeah okay now they're me deleted
now i can move you in and now i can hybrid usability and i go here then i will transform
okay do you have your you know what just just pretend that you have everything that you need to
around what what what do i have what do i need to add here just tell me what do i need to uh fly
is it he yeah i just add because i added in a hybrid form i had two separate features one
ten bird feathers and one ten bird feet and yeah better there you go those didn't that over is it
is it good now uh uh no it's still on 60 60 should be 80 80
oh it's only adding the proficiency okay let me do walk
add 20 more right yeah same as five why
20 submit and also lightening also lightening and then the resistance
okay that i need to copy from your first transformation
and that's what i also i also had to look enough how they both
i think it's not from your is it from your hybrid i don't know yeah oh i added it into your base
hybrid not in the like the form hybrid because it was common right uh it's fine um where is it
there it's on the bird feathers
and your bird feathers and tender bird speed yeah yeah so i just need to remove the
fucking bowl should i add a keyer then well i can't stay on a hundred hundred that's fine
okay there you go i think everything should be fixed now can you check it
uh 80 80 yep that's 80 80 and that's by nan's and earth right okay uh so you see and i should
be on 16 what the temperature because i only took four right with the people shattered yeah so 12 right
well no i wasn't 20 but and the shadow was eight i have done the resistance but that's half
that's 12 and that's 14 or 16 16
why is this token still old why not old uh base token base there you go
i also don't have active to see this formation it just for one
what and that's formation is just for one form one yeah i haven't given you the permission yet
okay i was gonna do it after after this
i think we're good for now then i just noticed that
bro i swear to god i'm gonna i'm gonna lose that
this should be fine okay as he's getting out of the uh armor as like he's bursting out of the armor
you see the horns of on his body starts to grow as he takes like a half rhino half human form his
feet starts to grow out of the uh like armor feet just breaks out of it his armor starts to crumble
because it cannot hold the his whole body he starts to grow he's even bigger than you at this point
but here already it was of it was it was it was like now it's like more big it's like around 10
10 five a lot of people like i'm just lead and tall yeah
uh as he snorts it goes
i'm to put you to bed i still have a free beauty of rose i still have a fee for you
yeah yeah you have two more attacks by the way yeah that's what i mean the free
free beauty of rose yeah
no that's six attacks right no fury of rose only two attacks so that's two so that's four attacks
that's it yeah how do you how do you get six now if you do normal punch then extra attack
that gives you one more normal punch and then you do furtie of blows that gives you two more okay
which is good x yeah go ahead go okay two more attacks you got the six i don't know
attack
all of this is like thunder right uh lightning lightning yeah 24 hits
let's go
13 hits no no 13 hits 13 damage yeah go ahead and another one yeah another one
i saw that in the table i was like what the fuck
29 hits apparently i think 29 hits i have 10 renan doesn't head you should just give up
like what's the fire well
another 12 so that's
25 total yeah
okay as you just as he's like trying to get ready you just start hitting him in the face
uh yeah he just he just takes both of it the hits he's just gonna position himself
and he's just going to ram you straight up well uh i'm a is he gonna fly
no he's not gonna fly he's gonna go straight you you fly up he's going to go straight
and let me see what happens for the attack oh no not not 20 you get uh that's an eight
yeah i don't know already 18 what 18 hits you actually 18 is my AC
well fuck this is token go i don't know oh it's beneath you i was like what the fuck
uh let me see how how far does he go when he rams
okay he's just gonna go straight and just bump into this guy this statue as you you can see from
up there the statue starting to crumble it turns around he goes and he is going to
cast fear
uh with some save yes
as it's like wave off just dried stands upon you uh 18 uh
satin yeah you save it uh i don't think cat it does anything else right
to do it oh no
uh did he did he did 30 foot true uh yeah it doesn't do anything other than that okay go ahead
it's your turn oh yeah uh wait i need to read something first
all right um the clone cosco lightning i'm gonna like form some
quantum clouds between my hands and just pull them up and call a lightning all right
uh cosco you know that yes i know i don't have spousal thoughts
just make sure you're not using more than your send that i i know i i got i gave myself two good
level spells if that's enough is other game you so itself four two four three one four three two
what four three go well one two three oh the spells here no let's find the roll the damage
well you need to make uh say first that save oh my god what the fuck bro
i have the light made i have the light uh what was the taxi yeah i think you can delete the
area it's like just oh no no no it's cool it's cool
11 you failed all right that's 3d 10
and i can keep costing that as a bonus action by the way
and i'm not separating as long as you're concentrating you're flying so you're probably
gonna concentrate yeah
oh i got what happened i don't know what happened let me put it back on again
oh no that's the wrong one i placed let me just roll keep let me just roll 3d 10 normally
21 that's okay that's all right
there we go no i like name
uh that's your move right that nothing else
uh the lightning isn't action
you can use a bonus red yeah that's my that's my that's me that's holding okay
uh he is at this point he's dropped his hammer he is not you going to use his hammer
he's going to just smash this uh statue right in front of him
uh
oh my god dude smash the fucking statue okay he's not gonna do it he's just smashing the statue
and the statue is not breaking but there's cracks starting to form it's your turn
is your flying around you look at him and you kind of understand what he's trying to do maybe i don't know
uh
you're turned oh no it's an action too called lightning
it's not a bonus action that would be very OP it would be insane
but it's um so i might as well right maybe allow the dexay please
okay uh let me be good xay he has not good dex so you're okay now mine he saves 18
oh i still hold damage yeah yeah roll the damage
or is that bad? Yeah, I'm moving away a bit. I can't I move away a bit because I can move. Right.
Yeah, you can move. I don't know. Okay, what was I doing? Okay. I don't know.
He's gonna keep slamming on the thing. Break the fucking pink please for the love of God. You have a lot of
Oh my god. What the fuck is this this strength? Okay, Jesus Christ. He's not he's still punching at that thing, but he will use his bonus action to
or of vitality heal. Yes, yes, and fucking concentration on this Jesus Christ.
This is our or vitality not work on yourself. No, it does work on yourself. What the fuck?
No, man. I figured out. He heals for eight. Zero turn. Yep.
Uh, Dexave. Might as well just. Yeah, please. Might as well. Right.
Yeah. Uh, you're just flying around him and just fucking calling like
yeah, it feels. I should level up to it. Yeah.
Wow. 15. I keep getting less. Yeah, every time it's becoming less. 21. 15.
Oh, you did eight damage and he healed for eight. Oh, God.
All right. The damage still strikes him. It doesn't seem like it's affecting him a lot, but he does
loot his concentration. No, he doesn't. Okay, no, man. Um, okay, he's gonna keep punching.
Miss, miss, miss. Oh my god. Jesus Christ. Do anything. Please. Oh my god. I don't know what he's doing.
I don't know what he's doing. He's rolling threes like back to back threes. Oh my god.
Okay, go ahead and turn. Dexave, please. All right.
Is this reminding me a lot of Bob's fight? I don't know. It does not.
It does not bow to well for you. It goes exactly. Do we need to go down?
Do we need to go down to how Bob? I don't know. I don't know. Do you?
Uh, 14. Oh, this is, oh, no, that is a safe. All right.
Roll the damage. I feel like you make use of your fullerio blows.
Free, free of blows, man. Yeah, give me a second. I'm going to move closer.
Okay. But this is just fun. Okay. Just taunting him at this point.
15. So seven, seven. Seven.
So what was it? Yeah.
All right. I'm moving a bit closer.
Still in the air. But closer.
Fly, fly.
Please, please break the thing. Please.
No, don't. Oh, yeah, he did. Did he?
No, 16 and 15. My god.
Why do you have a plus tricks to its red, man?
For what purpose do you have this strength?
No, mine. No, go ahead. He's still trying to break the fucking statue for the last three turns.
That's essentially like 15, 15 seconds. He's been punching the fucking wall.
Even more.
Let me see if I can just use free of blows or I need to do an action for attack action for the
beautiful. Let me have to. Oh, yeah, I need to attack action. Okay. Yeah.
Just going to. I think you can only once, flare your blows.
Well, you need to attack first to use free of blows.
I mean in baller's gate, you don't need to. You have to, you can just flare your blows from the
beginning.
With the end of ball, there's a gate. It's the same thing.
They're doing you. Oh, no, baby.
Yeah, 14 does not hit. Second.
Does not hit. It's
No, you're not. You're not. We're back at mouthless.
No, we're 60.
Ah, that does it.
All right. More.
Not one. Nice.
Perfect.
Okay. I can get into him like ramen to him.
Wait, no. What was this HP?
I don't know.
81.
Sorry. I put him at zero.
Yay. You won. Nice.
He's just going to ignore you. Punch into him.
Oh, he just ignores you.
My god, can you roll?
Okay, finally, to the price.
He finally like with this last punch, like after this like,
flurry of blows, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
He's going to grab the broken piece as the fucking statue starts to fall.
This is going to grab the statue and just hurry at you.
All right. Let me roll.
Let me grab any fucking. What was it?
Let me grab an arrow. No. I mean, anyway, you should have finished your
work.
21.
It's all right. The stasha will do bludgeoning.
All right. No, the flag missile.
So you can do the flick missile. Let me see how much damage does it does.
Falling statue damage.
Just use a fucking piece of rubble.
It's a lot of dice.
I mean, just fix on because it's just a rock righty.
So she just started to rock.
It's a big statue, bro.
It doesn't jump the whole statue, does he?
Yeah, he's going to jump the whole statue.
He's doing this.
This is breaking some off.
Okay, falling 20,
1d6 plus to a per 200 pounds.
So it's going to be probably like
200 pounds.
It's going to 1,000 pound statue.
Yeah, 56 is good.
It's not good.
As the statue starts to fall upon you, what are you doing?
16.
I don't know what's it average?
16, 16.
He's rolling very bad.
I don't know.
It was like 2, 4, 1 and 3.
And 1, 6.
16?
Yeah.
I think I have a chance to deflect.
Yeah, try it.
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Or you can deflect or you can deflect.
Well, I can just try to negate that right first.
And then I can maybe throw it back.
Yeah, yeah.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
You think?
Oh, yes.
He was trying to like pin you to the ground essentially.
No.
8.
So you take 8 damage as this like
thing slams you.
And basically just
shoves you into the ground.
Wait, that should be, but
nope, it's more.
It's
how come is only
doesn't do one thing?
Why is it zero?
Yeah, it should be
1d10 plus brawl plus dx.
So that should be more.
So plus dx is
yeah, I don't know what, what is your next?
13 plus 5.
It's pointing.
So that's 13.
Yeah, still doesn't complete negate that.
Yeah, you do take some damage, which is 3.
You're a 13.
HP, but you are pinned down under the rubble as the rubble falls on top of you.
You can do a strength check to get out of it this turn.
What are you doing?
That's his turn.
He's just going to chuck this statue at you.
Your turn.
Do a straight string.
Yeah.
Another good thing for me.
Him getting ready as like, like,
kicking in the floor as to just slam into you.
Okay, he's going to ram.
Oh, let me, uh, con say first for the like,
yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I keep the lightning.
Yeah, you keep the lightning.
Uh, it's gonna.
Let's see if he fucking does anything.
Okay, 19.
Finally, Jesus Christ.
Uh, okay, let's see.
What's that?
What's that minimum damage?
No.
Plus four.
Um, okay, as he just slams right into you,
you will, uh, wait, is there a check?
Let me check.
Let me check if there's a check.
Check if there's a check.
If the target is medium or a smaller creature, you're not medium.
No, I am medium.
You're, you're like, not, not in this, like, but you are taller than medium.
For Lunarians, I've kept you medium because there's no option other than that.
Just for the token safety, I've kept everyone at medium, but you are taller, so you're not
medium.
Oh, I'm technically I'm nine five and, uh, large started then.
Yeah, exactly.
Oh, so I'm mind your, your prone.
It's going to take half your movement, which isn't much, but you're prone.
Oh no, my older 40 feet of movement I still have.
Oh my god, Jesus Christ, I keep doing it and you've targeted at him.
That's why I'm doing damage.
There we go.
Uh, it's five damage to you, which is each temp.
Uh, yeah, he's just going to ramp straight into you and you just go straight through.
And you're going to go prone.
It's your turn.
Uh, so the rubble is off me, right?
The rubble is off you.
Yeah, he just straight up just slams it through the rubble, slams into you, just go straight through you.
So another con say first.
All right, you're doing call lightning?
Yeah, yeah, you for you.
No, I'm.
Yeah.
Yeah, that's above them.
Did you lose it?
I still have it.
No, I don't have it.
I rolled the bubble.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
The safest eight.
So yeah, yeah, that's fine.
Go ahead.
I mean, it's fine.
Next to me.
Might as well just hit him if I move it.
Attack.
24 hits.
Drenched.
11.
Another one.
Does it?
Well, the damage.
The mosh.
It was a three or four.
So first,
I'm going to do a three or four.
So the first one you did Ram, right?
Or the first one you didn't Ram?
No, because I was only, I only moved five feet to just three.
Five feet is okay.
Go ahead.
One more.
So one more.
No, three.
Yeah, just to be sure.
Not 20.
So roll the max damage for one day and then just roll one damage.
Just do normal damage and I'm going to consider the other one max.
Just add a D, just add a D6, right?
A 6.
So that's 10 to 16.
So sorry.
The damage is plus eight.
And then two plus six is 16.
Yeah.
Uh, the fuck is this?
50 damage, okay.
50 damage.
All right.
You essentially run up to him.
Just boom, boom, boom, boom.
Like lightning strikes every punch.
It makes like lightning sound as you just slam into him.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
force four punches.
Quick as fuck.
And he just drops to his knees at this point.
He gets up.
What are you doing?
Yeah, flying up.
Let me see if I can
get to the hammer.
Yeah, I can't get to the hammer.
He's going to dash to the hammer.
He's a grab it and he's going to, first of all,
magic weapon.
Magic weapons concentration.
When does it go off?
Is it a concentration?
All right.
The spell answered,
if you cast it again, okay, never mind, never mind.
He has the concentration on it.
So the magic weapon's still there.
So he's just going to do shatter.
Uh.
Hey, the console.
Matches the console.
So that's the succeed that saves.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah.
I'm confused.
But okay.
I don't know.
Roll my favorites.
Sure.
Uh, this is 15.
So half of 15 is seven.
You're going to one.
You're one team, but you are out of the chatter.
Wait, no.
I am still resistant.
So that's half of the safe and then half of damage.
Oh, it's four.
Yeah.
Give me back my four tenth.
By, uh,
right.
It's your turn.
What do you want to do?
He looks very weak.
At this point, it's like nostrils are bloodied.
His whole arm arm is like shredded at this point.
We get in close.
Charging at his face.
Okay.
That's it.
20.
I don't imagine anyone else beating him honestly.
Because
that's 17.
Yeah, go ahead.
And another one.
That's it.
What's your minimum damage?
Eight.
Oh, okay.
What are you doing?
So I chose that them and the small cloud of
small lighting cloud eyes.
Mate.
I'm just going to like call it back and put it in my
just concentrating it above and when I hit them, it just likes him.
Trying it.
So in the final point, so just the lighting comes down on his face and trying it.
Okay, as like the smoke comes off of him,
the he just puts his knees on the ground and just falls face flat into the ground.
Do you want to kill him with the lightning or do you want to just knock him on?
Uh, yeah.
Oh, good.
Yeah, but I don't think you can control the lightning.
It's technically a rage.
Yeah.
You're doing the fist.
Well, it's more flavor and just my head.
Yeah, yeah.
This but it's flavor ice.
That's fine.
You want to use your any what do you call it?
Inspiration or no?
Well, I have to do it if you gave another one, right?
You don't need to.
Yeah.
I mean, no, I don't think about it.
Okay, so as the lightning strikes, the first one, the second slam,
you just walk away from him and the second lightning strikes and he falls down.
And that's going to be it.
But that will take a ski and go up.
That will put one level of exhaustion to you because of the leveling up.
But you do get out of here.
This form you do have your whole HP pool.
Why is that?
Bro, do you want me to level you up and give you full health and not give you exhaustion?
What do you want for me at this point?
Yeah, you gain one level of exhaustion and you will fall unconscious as well.
Oh, there's a flanking one now.
I didn't see that.
Is there any unconscious ones?
There we go.
See, now they're not going to interfere with your fight.
Happy?
Cause I fucking destroyed them.
All right.
I'm going to go.
Have fun with that piece?
Have fun there.
Yeah.
Have fun.
Yeah, I'll be back.
Yeah.
Hello, hello.
It's your turn.
Finally, after what?
Fucking four hours or three and a half hours or not bad.
I don't.
All right.
I'm not.
Okay, sure.
All right.
Can you see your token?
Yep.
Hey, what the fuck?
Where's the wall?
What the wall here?
This is this is not a wall down here?
Can you see through it?
Oh, you can see through it.
Well, I could get a map.
There we go.
Token.
Is this?
Now it should be good.
Oh, there we go.
That's what I didn't want you to see.
Is the fucking map is all fucked up.
Anyway, your line face down
in as this like,
what was it?
The dagger is like right into your chest.
You cough up some blood.
You fall face down.
Turn around.
Kota is right in front of you.
Staring you down.
As he's trying to smash the other blade in.
And he says,
it's time for you to disappear.
And finally, you hear his voice.
This is the end then.
I went away for a while
because taking your wings was not that easy.
Oh boy.
You want to survive, yes?
What's it to you?
Well, it makes my job a bit harder if you die.
I need someone to take me to my whistle.
Not what is it?
And yourself to me
and I will destroy this garbage.
This insect right in front of you.
Crush him.
But no less.
Cruelty than of crushed many others.
I thought you said you had other people that you could get to help at your vessel.
Well, I'm not going to lie.
You dying will definitely be annoying.
More like a chore.
Got to wait another 100 years for someone to find me.
And then I get my vessel.
For me, it's nothing.
More than inconvenience.
I would like to get it as soon as I can.
What do you say?
Yes or no?
I don't need you to beat him.
As you say that, the flames behind your back start to burst as like these
flames just start to take shape and it fuses into your
void hands as these astral arms come back in.
And he just laughs and just
the voice fades away as you're back in your body outside.
Can you double click your sheet at it?
Go to brawler level yourself up.
What did you roll for health?
I don't want to.
I think you could.
I think it was five.
It was the average, I think.
You put it in a chat somewhere.
I know that.
Was it in a lunar fall?
I think it was.
I think it is.
Yes, six.
Yeah, that's the average.
Just take average.
For HB in the next.
Next.
That's a spirit point increase.
Double fruit uses increase.
Fireball.
Boom feet.
Oh.
You already have.
And then I was.
Yeah, it adds it automatically.
But I change fireball to mode of health.
So I'll delete fireball.
All right, delete fireball.
You have mode of health.
All right, I'm going to leave it up to you as these flames start to surround you
as he's trying to drive that knife into your head.
What are you doing?
To us about everything that I was using active.
Really?
Right.
My arm and everything.
Yeah, everything would still there.
Just take a long rest.
Okay.
Are you on private?
Just make sure you're on private.
Private, whatever.
Blind GM, whatever.
I've exam.
I should be.
Yes.
Let me just make sure everything stays enabled.
And then I saw the feast as well.
To activate it.
Oh, no.
Yeah.
You know, apply haste on you.
There you go.
Okay.
The knife is in my chest right now.
The other knife is your in your chest.
And he's like trying to put the other knife in.
But the force from the fire is just throwing them away.
I'd like to use the actual arms to take the knife out and then
rust all for art at him.
Okay.
The attack.
Go ahead.
Wait.
I said I'll change up how I do things once I.
Where is the stunning shrine?
Check it in.
Smooth you up top.
First swing,
Spongebob.
Not 20.
God, you can't make this shit up, bro.
We should with my freaking unharmed master bug.
Okay.
So then I'm going to use a stunning shrine called that one.
Nice.
You said for great damage, we're doing max one and then another D8.
Yes.
I'll just roll the crit damage and then just do it afterwards.
So that's going to be
A plus H plus five.
14 plus five.
19.
The first one hits for 19.
All right.
And then the stunning shrine.
Let me do a con save.
He succeeds.
I'll bring it.
Let's try again.
Spells.
One more.
Going in one hits.
Max damage.
Nice.
11.
Stunning shrine again.
He succeeds again.
How many attacks does that one two three?
You have extra attack too.
Are you can do flurry of blows and do two more attacks again essentially?
In the mind next turn.
Extra attack attack.
Hits.
Another eight.
It succeeds.
Jesus.
Oh my god.
Okay.
That'll be my turn.
So two normal attacks and without using any key points just one bonus action.
Right.
That's it.
Yes.
So one attack.
It's going to be 38.
The haste.
Yeah.
This is this will this will push him away.
And like he just gets again embedded into this rock here.
And he starts to get up.
You see him laughing.
He's cackling at this point.
Goes.
You know what I never never wanted to use this but guess I'll have to.
He turns.
He pulls out a wild of like this green fluid that you saw from Hallow's
laboratory in in Calisto.
You see the six six symbol drawn on it.
He turns the wild and it's going to turn into this like infinity symbol.
As he rotates the wild and the pin's going to pop out.
He's going to inject himself and he turns into like a hybrid hyena of some sort.
Where is that?
He is going to create a weapon in his hand.
And he's going to hit you with that weapon.
You see this blade that he pulled out of this ethereal zone.
It's like it is like eluding that exhuming like this black hockey.
And he's going to try to hit you with it.
I think he just dashes straight toward you.
There we go.
25.
Okay, if it's a 25, I could use a double fruit used to make my AC 25.
It can't try that.
Is it is a reaction?
Yeah, if the attack matches, it doesn't work right.
No, no, it doesn't.
Okay, then I will use one of my double fruit uses to get my shield up.
What happens essentially as he slams you with this blade,
he will just go straight through it because he does not know how to use hockey.
He just emanates our mimics what people do with hockey.
He does not know how.
And he said, his attack just misses.
He just goes straight through you as you just wrap around him.
It's your turn.
See, this is a fun little game or plank.
What I think it's over now.
Let's give it one more try.
Hopefully he fails this time.
Lines, damage, stunning shark.
Did I apply that to myself?
I did.
What?
Stangest, right?
I'm not targeting myself.
Oh, I see, see.
Let me.
Yeah, he fails.
Finally!
Okay.
One.
Come on.
That is this.
Two.
18 hit.
18 hits.
So that's my regular action,
face action, actual attack, actually.
One more because of the
bonus action.
Now 20.
Why'd you slide?
So plus six to 22.
So that's 28.
28.
What was the first one?
21.
The first one.
It was 20 to 21.
21, 21, 21, and 28.
What next?
Oh, 18 cuts.
The Vendee 8 gets 28.
No, no, the Vendee 8 is funny.
Okay, that's the first attempt.
Eight.
Yeah, yeah.
20, 28 and 22, 28 and 21.
So 28 and 21.
Three.
Four.
Enter a tech attack.
You can use your extract attack as well.
Extra attack, normal attack, haste attack.
You have your bonus left.
And you can use flierablos on that.
Yeah, my flierablos that I have left.
It's something when I have left.
That it's.
Oh my god.
22.
So we have my regular tech, extra attack, haste attack,
bonus actions.
No, that's all.
It's only five.
No, no, no.
The flierablos is two attacks.
But it's also the bonus action attack.
So that counts as.
Okay.
One is your main attack.
Then you do your haste attack.
Then you do your extra attack.
Then you do your bonus.
So that's two more strikes.
That's five.
Yeah, I did all five.
You did five?
Did you miss one?
Yeah.
Oh, you missed one.
Yeah, yeah, you did miss one.
What was the last one?
22 as well, right?
Yeah.
Let me see what the damage is.
71, Jesus fucking Christ.
(soft music)
Let me see.
He succeeds.
So did he lose the concentration?
He did.
The blade disappeared from his hand.
As soon as you like punched him with the first hit,
he just drops the blade and the blade just disappears.
And you just slam the other face.
The other face, the other face, you just keep slamming him.
And
after that, he's gonna use his...
He is stunned.
Yeah, he is stunned for one turn.
It's your turn again.
All right, love this.
I think he gets...
Great.
No, never mind.
That's a tie.
You have your devil fruit users increased as well, right?
Or no, not yet?
Yes, it increased.
That was...
Wow, it was a piece of shield.
Don't think I only have one left.
He should still be...
He's done it to the end of my next turn.
This is gonna be my next turn,
which I get all five.
Oh my god.
Of course, next, first turn.
It's two.
[Music]
This is three.
I did that with normal one accident.
I'm just re-rolled once.
I think that would fail.
Let's go.
Not 20.
Oh my god.
So 34 damage.
So that's right here to...
34 and 19.
It's all I can do because I'm out of...
Spiritpoint.
It's all ready.
How does haste last for 10 rounds, right?
Oh, one minute, yeah.
10 rounds, yeah.
10 rounds has not even happened like in this whole fucking fight.
33 and 19.
All four damage.
Now we're doing this without my advantage.
All right, the stun is gone.
He kind of...
Essentially, what happened in the last minute is just you just pummeled
straight into his body.
Boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom,
like eight hits back to back.
And he's like, at this point, his whole body is like shaking up.
You see these impact zones on his body.
Just...
Just curators, essentially, on his body.
Let me see.
He's gonna take out another one off.
The blade slashes that essentially like black hands blade slashes.
And he's gonna steal wind strike.
He fails.
Does he?
17, yeah, he fails.
As this another like wind slash just swishes past you.
He just lost all control at this point, except to you.
He's just whimpering at this point.
Just falls down.
Just gives up, essentially.
What are you doing?
I'm gonna laugh.
You talk all this about the people
continuously failing.
You weren't even all that yourself.
Then I'm gonna grab this head so you can look up at the bells.
That last bell you heard.
That is the one that matters.
And that is the one that brought your end.
And then I'm just gonna swing it in.
We said he's on the ground.
So is he prone?
No, no, he's just like on his knees.
Okay.
I think it doesn't hit.
Does it roll the damage for this?
22 is not gonna kill him.
Roll again.
That's too tight since he's doing it.
Doesn't hit.
Okay.
I didn't breathe so far, right?
Yeah.
You had one more.
I mean, you can do two more.
I don't have any key points.
I have to do a flurry.
Why?
I used the model and stun strikes.
That missed.
Oh, I see.
This is not sure.
Let's try to make sure.
Does it?
Yeah, that's gonna.
What do you want to do?
You want to kill him?
Yes.
Okay. How do you kill him?
And you said he was on his knees.
And after I got his head,
I just met actress.
I'm just gonna throw his head into the floor and then punch right after.
It's massive.
It's hard.
As you put him down, he
sighs like this relief.
Like you've let him go.
But as soon as you just,
the slam him down,
you just slam another punch right in his face.
And that's it.
That's the end for this guy.
And you will also take one level of exhaustion
and fall unconscious.
As soon as you grab the
grab the key, you just fall unconscious.
Let me move to the other guys.
Oh, just give it.
You know what?
I'm gonna bring everyone back and top.
What the dog doing?
One of the ones are done.
Roma don't say anything.
Well, Roma's dead.
Bob is missing.
Bob.
He's dead.
Is he creating a character?
No.
Bob.
Bobby is not even in here.
Rob is gone.
All right.
So what's going to happen after you fall unconscious,
after like 10 to 20 minutes,
every one of you are woken up by
a group of, a lot, every one of you.
You
baptized.
Where is where is
where is the man?
Oh, wait.
I have it all.
Hey, why do you have two points of exhaustion?
Because of my, uh, the haze.
No, no, no, not a woman. Oh, yeah, he's, yeah, haze gives. Well, no, he doesn't give exhaustion,
but he gets an authority.
What?
What are you doing?
Hey, stop it.
Oh, haze doesn't give an exhaustion.
Does it?
He's just become a tarjit for turn.
Yeah, you just become a tarjit for turn.
That's fine.
All right.
You both are here.
And let me see what NPCs should be here.
Uh, it's going to be.
Riff is going to be here.
Was not that much heard.
T-core.
Well, they've got fucked.
Bob is here.
Let's go.
Hey, T-core were fighting together.
Bob, step the fuck up.
Don't say anything.
Okay.
Bob's dead.
I have to keep Bob with five hours.
T-gores here.
He's here.
As both of you start to,
let me stop with the skyfall.
We put on a normal.
No, you gotta leave that.
That shit was dope.
In the sky.
Fuck.
In the tremble.
I'm about.
In front of you, you see this guy.
As he's trying to like poke you awake.
Hey.
I think I'm going to be fine.
Uh, Malthus, you will wake up first.
Yeah.
What are you doing?
I'm grabbing his hand as he poke like,
you can stop that.
Oh, great.
Everyone's here, right?
Looking around.
What about floor two and three?
Uh, well, we didn't see anything.
We just heard like a loud howl.
And that's about it.
I'll wake up my uh,
of this.
Matisse, you are like shaking awake by Malthus.
Out of instinct, I'm going to grab his hand.
It was someone threatening me.
Okay.
And I'd be like, Malthus?
Yep.
Did you get your key?
Did you win?
Right.
Right here.
And then I'll.
Good job.
Then look around.
Where's Bob and Roma?
Well, uh, I heard something from below my floor.
So, uh, maybe something might be happening with Roma.
And I'll look over and see Kate and Riff.
Yeah.
Kate.
How'd you do?
I think I did well.
For our.
Did you bring it back?
Here's the key.
Captain.
Good job.
And who are you?
Uh, all right.
Yeah.
Um, you know, I think it's better if the other guys explain
themselves.
Where did he go?
Where's the fucking guy go?
Uh, uh, as soon as he says that, you see like a kind of
ash forming around you guys from on top
and as a body forms out of the ashes.
All right.
Then is everyone accounted for or no?
Bob and Roma.
I'll try to get up to like, try to make my way there and then just like
stumble because of the exhaustion.
Yeah.
I don't think you should be moving.
Anyway, um, Bob, you said
the machine should be there by now.
He should be able to handle it.
Just in case you should probably go and check on him.
He's not much of a support guy.
He just follows orders.
Dravo, how about you take these two and bring him to Bob?
If you need me here, here you go.
You know what?
Maybe I should, maybe I should come with.
What about the other one?
Roma, Roma.
He was on floor three.
On floor three, we just didn't go inside.
Why?
With floor three?
I don't know.
Someone was supposed to, Dravo's did you not stop by floor three?
He looks at Dravo's and Dravo's goes, uh, what?
There was like a white big monster.
So I did, I did not think I should instaur up.
I think they did.
They're fine.
I'll start stumbling for it's for three.
Yeah, I'm also, I was gonna go to the, it's time, but I can't move to this.
Okay, how about this?
I move one of you to floor three and one of you to, or um, okay.
Malik.
I don't have time for your stuttering.
Get it together.
Okay, it puts his hands on the floor as like a PVC pipe like shows up around here.
Like a green PVC pipe just pops up and he goes, you can go down that if you want to go to floor three.
Uh, you jump inside and you're gone.
Malik, what are you doing?
You following him or are you gonna go to bar?
Uh, I guess I'll save bar by game.
How the hell are you going to fall in down?
Uh, you'll not retain falling down.
Okay, I'm going to do this.
I'll press up this guy's hand.
Go, Rova.
Okay.
Um, so one, only one of you can take the healer who is this guy with you.
That was, that was what Drayvos was going to, but the only one who can fix someone up is, is, is, Sir Malik.
So you should probably take him with her.
Who wants him?
I'm already gone.
Yeah, he's already gone.
So I guess Malik will come.
Ah, alright, you know what, I shouldn't have signed up for this job.
I shouldn't let the other fucking fools follow their way through.
Anyway, open it up.
Another PVC pipe shows up.
He points at you, uh, Malthus.
And you, uh, go inside, I guess, following Malik?
Yep.
I don't know.
Guess I'll do it.
Okay.
Um, so,
so, before jumping out, uh, stage of cage, you rest up here.
We'll be back.
I'm, I'm going to go to Mikey.
Okay.
Two keys.
We'll take care of it.
Um, all right.
As both of you, uh, Malik and, uh, Malthus, you get inside the tunnel.
As soon as the tunnel opens, you find yourself in this,
uh,
let me,
be moved, you're token's in.
You essentially plop down and you start falling.
Malthus, can you do a deck save?
Ah, yes.
Is that in that 20?
Jesus Christ.
All right.
As you plop down, you fly, uh, into the, like completely, like a white room with, like,
weird layout of the whole place.
It's very disorienting.
Uh, there you go.
As you fly into the room, you see this guy with, like, a gas mask standing over Bob as this, like,
small, uh, like spider, like attaches itself to Bob's core.
And it's just trying to like, uh, essentially like welding the core at this point.
Uh, you see Bob is not responding at this point.
He's just lying there.
And, uh, this guy is going to just disintegrate and form himself around here.
Goes, well, well, I guess it's a good thing I came here then.
Uh, I will need,
oh god.
Is he another machine like you,
facade?
Guess he is.
Uh, he essentially like turns his hands into, like, this small molecular ashes as these,
uh, ash molecules start to grow inside of him.
And just, just like, uh, through his skin, you see that these ash particles just moving.
Uh, hey, talk guy.
It's going to take a while.
Let's say about eight to 10 hours.
I think it's best if we move him on our ship.
What do you say?
I suppose you can take care of this.
Yes.
I'll be fine.
Just get him out of here.
Okay.
As you're leaving the, the, the PVC pipe is basically still up there.
So he just points you up there and goes, you can leave from up there.
Also, didn't you want something from this guy?
Uh, babe, facade.
What the fuck were you doing?
Why did it take so long?
Uh, the, the mass guy just goes,
well, I was taking care of the mission.
The, the, the creature is dead and here's the thing.
Maybe thereafter he, like, takes this key and he points it at you.
This is what you're looking for.
It is.
All right, there you go.
He chucks it at you.
Grab it.
Okay.
And you fly up or do you want to leave Bob to these two?
Uh,
well, I first, I actually, I don't know who they are.
So, so I can actually, what are you?
Oh, yeah.
Drave, I was not telling you.
Anyway, um, my name is Malik.
Part of the Brave Heart Parts.
You were sent here by
Commander Mira to warn you about this guy called Rhea Sue.
Who is like a wanted pirate by our crew.
And he did some bad stuff.
We thought he was dead, but apparently he's the ruler of this place.
So just be careful, okay?
Oh, if you need our help, there you go.
Mira, let's probably have to say.
Okay, cool.
Uh, there you have to, there you go.
This is a transponder.
You can get back to me.
I'm going to be busy, but if you need, I'll send facade in.
For now, I need someone to carry this guy.
Alright, facade.
Just slowly.
Don't move him around a lot.
I'm just going to walk through the inside of the room, leave, get to, by the way,
we got your ship.
Some people were like taking it away somewhere.
Anyway, the ship is at the shore where you left it.
Our ship is right around the shore.
What?
Is it, is it right down?
It is how it was.
I'm not too sure if it's tied.
Well, the other people are still there.
Only three of us came in here just to make sure nothing goes wrong.
The other people still there.
If anything were to happen to you, they'll take care of it.
Anyway, I'm headed out.
If I take the body in both of them, just go away.
Now, on the third floor,
that piece, you see just a carcass lying right in front of you.
This carcass woman just torn apart her head on the other side of the room.
You can't see anything right?
I see the map.
Yeah, just this woman just torn into like two pieces.
Her head just completely torn off.
You also see around you just a bunch of deadminks strapped to like these
collars hanging from these trees, all these bodies like carved end.
Well, not minks.
You know what they are.
They are like transformed humans.
But for Roma, it was binks.
Essentially, that's what he thought.
And you see just a giant hole in the wall
leading outside in the Noble's District.
Dear God,
I'm going to run towards the hole after looking at the minks in a
Roma and they run towards the hole.
As you run towards the giant hole in the wall,
you just see beneath you just buildings just torn apart.
Just whole buildings just collapsed and you just hear this
how across the whole Noble District.
You don't notice, you don't see him yet.
He's just resounding just how.
You don't know where he is.
Oh, yellow from the whole Roma.
Roma.
Roma, can you do a perception?
Yep.
Um, where's my person?
Sorry.
Like, I'm nowhere.
Oh, let me, let me, let me bring your token back for one second.
There you are.
There we go.
Right, perfect.
Oh, the character she perception.
This is going to be horrible.
Just normal, right?
Yeah.
Oh, that ain't that bad.
I'm gonna hear it. I'm gonna hear him.
All right, you hear the noise.
You start walking or like just leaping towards it.
That the hole, I'm, I'm, I'm full of these.
No, bro, I am.
I am.
You are.
I am going to hawk that man down.
Oh, God.
Why is not the token not updating?
God damn it.
Want to create like, uh, let me give me a second.
Uh, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um, um.
Dimension grids.
It's fine.
Full red, full high.
Why is it like I love it?
I'm so bad.
For type token.
No, I'm gonna just, uh, can I just?
How do you increase the size of the token?
I don't understand.
Oh, there you go.
I see it now.
One, one, one, there.
There we go.
Think, nope.
Still, still the same.
Uh, uh, uh, uh.
You know what, I'm going to just do this.
Does this do anything?
No, of course not.
All right, um, um,
I'm gonna just, you know, just remove this.
Yep.
And I'm gonna
get you out from here.
I'm gonna move your size into this.
Let's see if it updated.
Yep.
Right in front of you, Baptiste, you see this like huge, uh,
beast running towards you.
Just leaping through window from like building to building,
the building to building and then he just, uh,
appears right, uh, in front of you, throwing you away from the wall.
As you guess, flung in.
And uh, the Roma scream was also heard by, uh,
can you roll it, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh,
perception, mouth is.
Oh, yeah.
Oh, yeah, this advantage is a fucking.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, great.
You did not hear this.
So, uh, but I'm gonna make a check for the other two.
No, I guess I'll just head up eventually right after the left.
I mean, yeah, but it's gonna take a couple of turns.
I'm gonna say that two turns after you can enter.
All right, you both enter into this.
Fight.
Uh, I'm gonna go.
Roma's music.
There we go.
All right, that teased.
Uh, let me remove you from the combatant first.
Roma, play your part, destroy him.
Are we rolling?
Yeah, roll for initiative.
Yeah.
No, no, no, no, this, not this.
Can you not see the token?
No, wait, wait a second.
It won't, it won't let me, let me, let me give you the ownership of those token.
Uh, transformations, long,
figure ownership, Roma, on there.
There we go.
Now you can use this.
So now I roll.
Yes.
He gets to go first.
All right, let's go.
You're, uh, wait, who's first?
Me.
He goes.
All right, he goes.
All of my stuff from before should be deactivated, right?
Uh, what do you mean?
You did not take a single hit of damage.
So yeah.
No, I'm saying like, how much time wise?
How much time was passed off?
Shortress.
Okay.
I said 20 minutes rate or 20 minutes.
Yeah, it should be enough for shortress.
I mean, I guess it's like 30 minutes rate.
Shortress is an hour.
Jesus Christ.
Yeah, it's fine.
I'm going to roll for shortress.
I think it can be a minimum to 30 minutes or something.
I was asking because I need to deactivate some things.
Yeah, yeah.
Everything needs to be deactivated.
You do have your seat.
I'll see.
Roman.
I still see blood in the door.
Oh, Roma.
You just had to go and do this.
This is what you want.
I'll get it to you.
Let's go.
One second.
Just so everyone knows, this is not a normal so long.
The fucking bitch injected him with something.
He got the fucking serum.
Yes.
And he finished her with like two fucking moves, bro.
Two rounds as she was over.
What I'm sorry about to do.
Okay.
The Roma is a constitution tank, so I'm not going to try to do that.
Sorry, I didn't know there's no temp HP for so long.
I think I have one weight.
I use sealed.
I have two uses of my double fruit left.
Okay.
Okay, no.
So how devil fruit things work is you have your spell moves.
You have the uses of your spells and then you have the two uses.
Okay.
So if you have like level five, you have two spells lots, I think,
for level three and four and what was it, Melvus?
I have four three two.
Yeah, it's four three two.
So you can use a level three two times and then level four four times,
level two two four times.
Then it's...
So one four two three three two.
Oh, one four.
Okay.
First level four, second level two, third level...
No, second level three, third level two, I think.
Dumbass.
Nice.
We'll pick it up later.
Go ahead.
Yeah.
You want to do haste?
Mm-hmm.
Go ahead.
That'll give me another action.
Roma, Roma, Roma.
Oh, Bob.
Bob, I think you can leave.
It's fine.
You're going to revive next turn if you want to leave.
You can leave.
Oh, you can leave.
He wants to stay Bob.
Come on now.
Bob is a G.
Sun's getting low.
Sun's getting real low.
All right, go ahead.
Oh.
21?
Uh...
Yep, that hits.
Let me check what's your AC-17.
17.
Oh, thanks for coming me.
It's fine.
You already know each other's AC.
He has updated AC because of his updated decks.
Oh, not 20.
Yep.
Oh.
Okay.
Okay, big dog.
23 and 21.
Is that going to knock you out?
That's crazy.
That's exactly the same amount of damage.
That is exactly the amount of damage that is HP is.
That's crazy.
All right.
What do you do?
Love tees.
I told you, as soon as I saw him,
and he pushed me back into the center.
Yeah.
I knew this is what has to be done.
And...
You know what?
I was...
Yeah.
It's crazy.
All you see.
Bro, his luck has been insane so much.
The one on one was crazy.
What the hate activates?
All you see is the blur as Nat towards him.
And then just...
Two punches.
I don't even move my...
You don't see my fist move?
You just see Roma's head snapped and he gets knocked out.
Roma, you guys just slammed into this wall
as you...
power down and just go to sleep.
Bro.
Holy shit.
It's only against...
Other.
Every time I fight one of our squad.
Yeah, you just want to have them.
You fought Malphins and you want to have them.
You fought Roma, you want to have them.
Malphins, you arrive a couple minutes later.
As you see...
Bob just...
Sorry, Baptiste is just carrying Roma's body.
Which I don't know how...
I don't know how.
And I just exhausted it at this point just...
You do see Roma after killing the woman.
He put the keys inside of his hat.
Even in his beast form, he was...
getting the keys.
That's a good boy.
Nof is going to help me out.
Oh, there we go.
Do we have all the keys?
You have...
Well, you can ask Malphys.
That's what I...
I have Roma's...
He threw it at me.
I have a...
No, no, I know.
But I can tell it would happen to Bob.
Oh, where's that hat?
There...
There's the game to the ship.
He was...
No, like...
I don't know.
How has worse...
He needs to fix it or something.
Malphys, for all...
You saw...
The Bob...
Bob was not breathing...
Looked fucked.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah, Bob did not look good.
It would be okay.
Also, those guys, apparently, they were...
They were a mere centen, so...
What's the question? Probably...
Guess she didn't trust us at the handle this.
(Slowly)
All right.
Well, you guys can carry Roma outside.
-Malphys. -Eventually, somewhere.
Yeah, somewhere.
We're just taking it slowly.
Hopefully, I'm just taking a leg and...
I mean, it's a leg and I just pull it slightly.
That's how I've been pulling my legs.
I'm not kidding.
I'm just drunk.
Yeah.
You are fastest, Leep, Roma still.
You will wake up once you get to the top floor.
Honestly, after this,
there's like so, so many fights back to back.
I would hope you would get leveled up.
All right.
So let's go to the fifth floor.
And now we are...
Everyone's here.
Except for Roma, let me bring Roma in.
There we go.
Roma, as soon as they put you down, you wake up.
What the fuck?
You are still...
You still feel like you've been just dreaming and playing tag.
What is it called?
"Shoot me."
What is "Shoot me"?
What happened in your floor?
Bro, where...
Where...
What the...
What's you talking about?
What happened before?
I don't...
I have no idea, bro.
I swear I saw some...
Yeah.
Oh, we have all the rings.
No, no, hold on.
Hold on.
Time out, boss man.
We missed somebody.
Bob's recovering.
He's not missing.
He's...
Where the fuck is he?
On the ship.
This guy right on the side of you, Roma,
will just turn to you and goes...
My name is Trevostomo.
How about you, sir?
It's obviously Roma,
because he said my name by four times.
I say, "You're the Roma."
All right, sir Roma, it's very nice to meet you. My name is Trevostomo.
The what, sir Roma?
Bro, calm down with that.
What?
Trevostomo?
Yes, yes.
You can refer to me as...
Breivore your Trevost.
All right, our Trevost's fine.
I don't know if I should trust you, because your name is literally "Thum" old.
I've gotten that a lot of times.
You're going to go to the office.
Well, Roma and Biro sent them.
Well, that's not exactly true.
What do you mean that's not true?
Well, I'm not really a part of the Black Hand prayer.
It's a...
I'm a...
Re-lancer.
I'm getting paid for this job.
So we shouldn't trust you.
No, I didn't say that.
See, everyone thinks that that's because my name is "Mohl."
I'm untrustworthy.
That's not true.
I'm very capable.
As he tries to lift his like...
The piper and she has on his hand and he does a bunch of squats as he's lifting it up.
And then he drops it in front of you, Roma.
Can I just pick it up?
Like...
You pick it up and it's like the lightest thing in existence.
It's all home.
What the fuck is this, bro?
No, no, no, trust me.
What are you headed for?
People with it gets real heavy.
No, could you get back to me?
It's not true.
Back to me, sir.
Can I try to like bonk him with it?
You could try to bonk him with it, but it's like very light.
It doesn't really do anything.
No, no, don't do it. It's gonna break. Come on. I spent a lot of money acquiring that.
So it's worthless.
If it's gonna break if I bonk him, you said it hurts when it...
You can try it again.
Tell me the truth right now, bro. I'll hit you with it.
Okay, okay. Let me show you something.
Can I get my weapon back first?
I'll fucking flip it to him because I won't be like,
it ain't gonna do anything like...
Okay.
As you give him the weapon, he grabs the weapon and he goes...
He grabs it and immediately like his hand just goes straight down and goes,
"Now you can pick it up."
You grab it again. Can you do a strength check this time?
Yeah.
Come on, baby. Come on, baby.
Come on, God.
You...
Oh, yeah!
Exactly to be...
As light as it was before, but this time when you grab it, it just falls straight down with you
and you're confused just what...
Where's to what happened?
Say what the fuck?
I told you!
Well, I am a man.
It's not like the...
Tennel tunnel.
I can create spaces.
I can go between spaces.
Well, not like large distances.
I can't do that a lot.
But I can manipulate like...
Waits and all that.
So that's why...
Carry this thing.
It looks intimidating as fuck, right?
No.
What do you mean? It's a vibrant.
It's a giant vibrant...
Take this frying pan, bro, and do that like...
Oh, that is...
That is, that is very sweet.
Where'd you get that?
I can't tell my secrets.
It's Chef's secret.
He had no clue.
Of course, of course, of course.
Makes sense.
They're just talking, Roma and fucking...
Who are you guys doing?
So, uh...
Rift.
But your children tell me what happened to the metal man.
He's just behind this door.
Which man?
The metal man.
The control.
Yeah, what happened to the metal?
Roma.
What?
Later.
Yeah, what were you saying to Rift?
So he's just behind this door?
It should be.
The Emperor is not awake.
We have a good enough timeline.
And at this point, we've defeated the sound for...
Maybe we can just kill the Emperor.
And end this for once and for all.
My goal essentially was to get inside and run the broadcast,
but we've gone so far.
We just get it over with.
He does not seem to have woken up yet.
So you have hope now?
Oh, seeing all of you beat the sound five.
Even...
Even Bob, who died, but...
Did he die?
I'm not too sure.
Oh, I hope he's okay.
Anyway.
He's going for upgrades.
He's going to say, "Well, he's going to do the honors."
It should be you.
I'm going to hand Bob's key.
Okay, he has three keys and you have two keys.
I'm giving Rift two keys.
Okay, as you hand them over, he looks at them and goes,
"I can't believe he finally doing this."
And without any hiding in...
Okay, let's go.
He puts these keys in this...
Imagine if this lock is very small.
That's where he puts the key.
That's where he puts the keys.
He puts the keys inside like all these five locations.
He turns them.
The gate starts to lift and roll away.
This gate completely rolls away to the here.
As this stairs just leads upwards.
Yes, this is it.
He's going to walk in front and keep going.
Keeps going.
Soon enough, if you go way inside,
the darkness keeps growing.
And at one point, you can't see anything,
except for the people who can have dark vision.
You see something tied up in these cables connected to him.
And Rift looks at it and goes,
"What the fuck is happening?"
As you get inside, you see
the lights around this room start to turn up
as soon as someone steps near a place.
And in the middle of it,
you see some guy with half of his body just missing
and a black orb in his chest just resonating.
And he's just tied up with a bunch of the wires connecting to him.
A bunch of like IVs connected to him, like pumping him with something,
just regulating his blood and everything.
The guy in the middle who's supposed to be the emperor is just in bad shape.
He, you are close to him. What do you want to do?
You told, um,
the office earlier, the emperor was someone associated with black hands crew at one point.
He was associated, well not really associated,
it was someone that the black hand pirates knew
and there was like an open bounty in like the pirate's group,
like black hand and every, every pirate captain knew about this guy
and they were out to kill him.
For some reason, you don't know what the reason was.
Would I have known about him with my, like, history?
Can you roll a history for me?
It depends because it could be anywhere around four years.
When you were gone, it could be around that part.
So you might know, you wouldn't have mentioned it if, yeah, yeah, you wouldn't know.
You wouldn't have mentioned it to you if the situation was resolved already.
And therefore the longest time knew that this guy was dead, apparently he was not.
If it's the same guy that they were after.
So I'll just let riff, riff, it's up to you now.
What do you want to do?
I'm putting it into this.
He's going to try to grab one of these cables and just like pull the plug.
He starts to walk up like a couple of stairs above where like this
apparatus like lies. As soon as he walks up, you see the thing in between the guy in between
his eyes start to open up and he just says, hold.
As his voice just resonates all around and all of you just stop moving and you can't even think
of moving at this point.
Is he just power wanted us?
All of you are stuck in one place. He starts to open like the other eye and you see him like more
clearly now. His face is like completely like masked over by this like oxygen mask that is
pumping oxygen right to his lungs. He looks around.
Can everyone make a wisdom check?
The other way is we have a disadvantage.
Now you can turn to public.
5, 9, 15, 7.
It's not worth it because it's like a very high row.
Well, I just wanted to see if anyone succeeds.
How high are you talking?
Very high. Let me see. Drey was very bad.
The one with the list will tell what is happening.
Roma tell where the song is 5.
I have no idea brother. I just tell the one the lady I did.
I ripped her apart.
The next one in line would be Drey was saying he got...
He looks at you.
You cannot resist either.
I'm not next in line.
You are next in line.
9?
Oh, that's history. No, my mouth is sealed.
He looks at you and he says to you the same thing.
The bell buyer has.
Okay. He looks around. He breathes.
Who are you with?
Make another wisdom.
All of us?
All of us.
I'm not going to end bother with the NPCs you guys handle this.
I fucking suck.
Yeah, Roma again, it's you.
Whatever Roma knows, just tell.
He asked who are you with? That's it.
Boss? I'm with boss man. He can tell you who we look at.
All right, Baptiste, you're here.
You tell him who you would.
The resisted.
We don't get it.
No, you didn't resist it.
No, I said the resisted.
Where?
The power of the stars.
Oh, you said your resistance, the resistance.
Yeah.
Okay.
Malph is I guess you say the same thing.
So I'm going to just accept that.
You.
He goes.
You are not from here.
Roll again.
Oh, shit.
Oh, my God, this is too funny.
Yep.
Hey, Baptiste.
Yeah.
It's Roma again.
Roma, go ahead.
What?
What you want, homie?
He asked, who are you really with?
You're from outside of this island.
Who are you really with?
You can say whatever Roma would feel, he would say.
Shit.
Luna, fold till we die.
Blackfalley, hang it from the backside.
All right.
That's you.
That's my third.
Get a boss.
That's he said.
We're the most broke.
Never heard of him.
No matter.
You in the middle.
You their captain.
Who's he talking to?
You.
Stop.
Okay.
Wisdom check.
No, no, that doesn't require a wisdom check.
I think you can say what you are.
You're the captain.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Unless you want to resist, like what he's asking you,
you can't say I want to resist,
then I can make you do the wisdom check.
Okay.
He looks at you.
He just examines you top from bottom.
He goes.
Can I be doing my examining while this is going on today?
You can do an insight.
What should I learn about him?
I feel like I should learn one of his ability scores.
He.
You know, let's check the hit points.
Okay.
While he's checking you,
you peer into him using your
void powers.
And you see as you are looking for his like
how healthy he is.
You look around.
You look like how he's shrung up.
He does not really.
And Kenny sends him things in your best.
They shouldn't be giving you an edge.
Okay.
That's fine.
You look around and as your eyes like
peers through this black orb that he has around this chest,
you see another ring.
Okay.
Hey, Baptiste.
You see another ring.
And he looks at you.
As soon as you notice that,
he looks at you.
He looks at your fingers.
And he goes.
They're back.
They're back for me.
No.
Bring them to me.
Bring them.
Baptiste.
Can you make a
charisma?
Is he saying?
Christmas safe.
Is he?
Is he saying bring them to me as he'll take them off my fingers?
No, just just walk you up to him.
Don't do it, boss.
Christmas check, Christmas check, no wisdom, just Christmas.
You see, I kind of want to automatically feel so he can take them from me,
but I'll do the Christmas.
Doesn't matter anyway.
Okay.
Can you make another check for Kana?
Oh, God.
See, this is how you know these rings weren't built for me to be wearing.
I'm so sorry.
With this advantage, yeah, that's fine.
Can you make another wisdom safe?
Okay, guys, it's going horribly.
Can you roll another, can you roll a deck?
Might as well roll all my saves right now.
This must be good.
Oh, my net 20.
Okay.
Your survival.
Oh, survival.
It's such a bad touch.
Kazaa. Nice. Let me average that up.
2299. What a relief.
Like you're looking to find the good ones.
No, next up, can you roll a religion?
Can you roll it?
And what about Slidel? You might actually succeed this.
I don't. You do.
You do. Okay.
As soon as he orders you to come toward him,
he orders you to come.
Guys, it's getting late.
The effect of his voice stops working on you.
And the voice comes back.
I'm not going to listen to this failure.
Now go, Malthus.
Take that, Reng.
Sorry, Malthus, that's bad to you.
Take that.
As you your effect, his effect does not work on you,
but you can choose to just walk toward him.
It's up to you.
You do hear his voice.
Take those rings.
I've tried that.
You want to walk towards him or no?
You want to resist?
I'm acting like I'm pulled in my his purse.
I'll walk towards him.
As you're walking toward him, the voice inside you go,
you think you can get rid of me?
I won't.
Won't take this whistle.
I will take the ring, though.
As your hand starts to like drag,
drag toward him, his chest,
and your hand starts to pull the core out of this guy's body.
And he starts to like just ride in pain.
You're right.
You're not missing anything.
Yeah.
I wanted some punch, you.
The point you did about that, Ravad.
As I'm swinging, I'm just going to say,
Diva, like, Ravad, Lushan.
We have a little revolution, bitch.
Viva, like, oh, that's that it.
Let's go.
Yeah, that's going to kill him.
How do you want to do it?
But I was like, I walked up.
Just swing.
Yeah.
As soon as you like touch his head,
his just head snaps and he just
like hangs by the wire.
As your hand just starts to grab the orb
and it's just trying to break it.
As this shock wave just goes through the room, now everyone can move freely.
Stop my arm.
Upon seeing that, I'm going to yell,
"Peace, love, or it's not a start?"
Karma, I just yelled, stop my arm.
Yeah.
Yes, I'm going to over.
Okay, everyone is going to try to pull you away from the orb.
Even Draveau's is going to help. Why not?
Everyone do a strength check.
I'm going to take an average.
Jack, look at me.
Hacker's.
This checks our redness advantage.
Check, check.
Are they?
Yes, because you're going to have exhaustion.
You also have exhaustion, almost.
I forgot.
That's all I'm rolling with.
Spin it.
Just make sure you
are all right.
19, Jesus Christ.
With this advantage.
9, 15,
19, 4,
4,
and 13.
You know what? It's looking good.
Why are you two?
Is it?
You only need one.
Oh my god, Romas, you're about to die.
Yeah, Bobo!
I don't know. I was I was changing it to one.
There we go.
Last roll.
15,
plus 9,
plus 19,
plus 4,
bro, riff is not doing anything.
He's a bard.
We expect that he's supposed to be a little bit more.
It's six, four.
I don't think it's going to work.
It's going to be like that.
64.
It's going to fall by one, two, three, four, five, six.
Yeah, I don't think it's going to work.
Is it going to be 10?
Oh, it is going to be 10.
It's 13, unfortunately.
You try to pull a baptism out,
but just his end is just going to go inside of the orb at this point.
As another shockwave goes through.
Can everyone make a deck safe?
I'm going to just roll for one of these people
and if one of them is obnoxious,
you don't go.
Someone move my die.
Okay.
10.
Yeah, he's going to just get boom,
boom, boom.
Why is Roma rolling with disadvantage?
Isn't he supposed to?
It's an exception.
That's an exception.
No, it's a saving stool, right?
Just a normal leader.
Oh, man.
Wait, he has a 10-year-old.
Doesn't matter.
Five and eight.
It's going to go through.
Deck safe for baptism.
You succeed.
You don't get flung.
Malfus, you succeed.
You can still one more try.
You can try to pull him out alone this time.
Get flung away.
It's better if you roll better
than the better chance of a better time.
I know.
Uh, that was a strike check, I guess.
Shreds check with disadvantage.
Baptiste, Shreds check with disadvantage.
I want to do something to try to help my off.
Oh, f**k, Shreds!
Sure, sure.
Go ahead.
What do you want to try?
I'm getting my ass for arms out.
Okay, you want to try with four of those arms.
Rolls, Shreds checks with disadvantage four times.
Think with ass for arms, I can use my wisdom
in place of strength.
So, sure, go ahead.
Is the better roll?
One, and I'm going to...
18.
Two.
Four.
I can't tell my soul is.
Okay.
There's too many dice on the screen.
Okay, I think it's safe to say that the average would be...
No, okay, actually.
Yeah.
No.
The average would be...
F**king mouth has pulled the three.
18, four, 16, 13.
Okay.
18, four, 16, 13 divided by five.
54 divided by...
Yeah, it's looking bad.
It's looking bad.
You're getting another ring, man.
Sorry.
No!
I still have my own arms.
Sure.
Do one more.
Why not?
I'll give you one more.
I have two arms.
So one.
It's four.
Okay.
You know what?
Malfa, go ahead.
I'll give you all your tries.
Roll another one.
It is advantage.
See, if we didn't have disadvantage.
Yeah, you were the one.
But, you know, you can't be cool and save everything.
17, 17 and four.
That saves it.
I don't know what it does.
It balances it.
What it does?
It does.
Let me check.
Oh, you don't need to check.
We know.
And four, 18, three.
Well, let's just...
Come on.
Four, 18, three.
At 75.
You know what?
You have better chances.
But I think the average else is in 3-7.
One, two, three, four, five, six, seven.
No, no, it's the same.
It's the other thing the same.
Oh, it's 7.
I can stop talking about D.
So if it's equal to go to the defender, right?
So they...
It's the speed.
Yeah.
Then you'll take the win.
What?
What are you doing?
If we win, if we win, then nothing.
But if it's not a win,
my bell is going to ring.
You do get your bell fragment back on the long rest.
So if you want to use that, you can use it.
If we win,
if we win,
no, you didn't win.
It's 10.
The average is 10.
You didn't win.
Okay.
Been up-fragment time.
All right.
You can roll only one more.
Change one more out of these.
You can pick Malthus's sorry S3.
Malthus has to roll though.
What?
14.
So you can replace one of those.
Four.
I'm changing my four.
And that's going to be...
Change the three.
Drop the three.
It's 12.
I can't pick up.
Yeah.
Malthus would have to roll if I change it.
It's 12.
Malthus, you get blown away without any checks this time
as the third ring
conjoints into the third finger on your hand.
Oh no.
Oh.
Okay.
I'll have to try to get the fourth as it is.
Already got...
Next time.
It doesn't work.
Dragon Ball Z.
Re-fog.
Does it get a fourth ring?
All right.
Five hours actually.
We were pretty close.
You have three rings,
Baptiste, but you will be pulled in and you will lose control.
And we will do to be continued from here.
At least Baptiste can't fly and hit Malthus now.